[Music]
10
times elements of bathrooms
we're looking very strongly at sinks and
showers elements of bathrooms
ten
[Music]
what times earth is going on with trump
and toilets
trump's white house toilet
would be clogged
clogged
[Music]
with documents that donald trump was
flushing down the toilet
[Music]
is this the explanation is this the
explanation
big massive dumpster
elements of bathrooms
ten times
[Music]
[Music]
god bless
the united states thank you very much
elements of bathrooms
look at those eyes man that that's that
that dude is gone ladies and gentlemen
alex jones
is now
very very upset with me
look at that that is a freaking predator
right there
who thinks he's smarter than you and
she's better than you and he's going to
beat you pac-man never talked to the new
cause pac-man's a loser
man's a loser he's not a knight at the
round table that's true
i'm not a knight at the round that that
actually is accurate that dude is gone
ladies and gentlemen
i was telling my children
the evil's growing it's coming what you
asked for is now at the door
[Music]
that is a freaking predator right there
who thinks he's smarter than you and
he's better than you and he's gonna beat
you
[Music]
now that we are up under our bodies
regime
my bag of mangoes now cost 11.
and 99
that seems like a pretty good deal a bag
of mangoes mango aren't mangoes like
three boxes
[Music]
bring my mangoes back down
[Music]
[Music]
the wisconsin crowd identifying from the
mangoes
forcefully affected the american people
[Music]
is
[Music]
well it's stream number two today i've
changed my shirt
i've showered
and we are here once again awaiting
failed former president donald trump in
waukesha
wisconsin scheduled to speak in 20
minutes which means he will speak
somewhere between 20 and 200 minutes
from now donald trump notoriously late
right side broadcasting is of course
covering it newsmax is indeed covering
it as well as you can see in the lower
right of the screen donald trump save
america rally wisconsin soon but for now
they have the great dick morrison by the
way the one time i interviewed dick
morris he hung up on me when i very very
lightly pressed him about some of the
nonsense he was saying and he just hung
up the phone on me that's on youtube
and you can check that out if you would
like
uh and of course today was day two of
cpac it was as unhinged as ever we will
have full coverage on monday by the way
i hope that you're subscribed to my free
podcast where we do an hour episode
every single day and then even beyond
that for our members we do the bonus
show oh the bonus show where you want to
make money everybody else that makes
money to find themselves is bad well
alex it sounds like you're going to have
a money problem very very soon here is
let's see where i can find it here is
the video of the award being read today
in the alex jones defamation trial folks
it is forty
five
point
two
million dollars check this out
oh i can't even hear anything let me use
my volume booster to crank this up for
you guys i have enough respect to have
proper audio number one
four million two hundred thousand
dollars whoa
question number two
twenty million five hundred thousand
dollars wow question number three
twenty million five hundred thousand
dollars
that's a lot of supplements
all right um
this question is the plaintiff's
attorney going to be laughing all the
way to the bank now as many of you know
it's not just
what you can be awarded it's what you
can collect so we'll deal with that
aspect of this a little bit later but
very very powerful stuff happening there
and not going so well there for alex
jones pac-man's a loser well focus on
yourself alex don't worry about me that
is a freaking predator right there
nothing predatory here
nothing predatory here okay sometimes i
tell you
about the insanity that i deal with on a
regular basis
emails tweets all this stuff here's like
just the epitome of the of the low
information stuff that i deal with i
spotted this chat message here
from a user named data who said wow had
to subscribe to chat that's commie as
hell and the rally isn't showing so must
be a liar
no the stream hadn't hadn't started yet
that's all and yes as an absolute bare
minimum spam prevention technique yes if
you want to chat
on twitch or youtube you have to be
following us on twitter subscribed on
youtube it's it's it's free it's really
not a big deal okay
and if it's so offensive just go
somewhere else please
please
uh
yeah all right anyway
i'm so glad that everybody's here
and um this is stream number two of the
day
stream number three in two days and
potentially potentially tomorrow there
will be another stream
if we fill this bar up with website
members and twitch subscribers and
gifted youtube subscriptions to a
hundred tomorrow i will stream the trump
cpac speech and it will be a shocking
and appalling night of insanity all
right i do have the clip yeah let's
let's close the loop on the alex jones
stuff
within moments
of the alex jones verdict roger stone
went on who the hell even knows where
right i mean it's like i guess this is
on infowars and and roger stone started
begging for money for alex jones look at
this alice jones is a good and decent
man he's a god-fearing christian uh he's
done more for this movement than perhaps
anyone you can name what movement
and right now
he needs our support
there's a place at the infowars store
where you can go just to make a
contribution if you're not in the market
for a book or one of his great products
yeah i don't know what the market for
books looks like
but i don't know that trump supporters
stone supporters and infowars fans are
necessarily in the market for books and
reading there's a link where you can
just send a yeah okay so anyway there's
that there's roger stone begging for
money for alex jones to pay his 45.2
million dollar settlement you hate to
see it couldn't have happened to a nicer
guy all right let me say some thank yous
people are dumping in subscriptions on
twitch i want to say thank you to
bobby
shamarev
zero cool
lily
beth graham and mari posseb
that is six putting us at six
also want to say thanks to some great
people gifting subscriptions on my
website desiree de long kevin gould lisa
raider joe raider and jason sickmeyer
very much appreciate all of you that
puts us at 11
super chat's starting to come in s prez
just spent fifty dollars
to get the words bowel movements up on
the screen isn't the internet an
incredible place someone just spent
fifty dollars
so that i would say the words bowel
movements and they would display on the
screen it's really an incredible
incredible place this internet that
exists all right let's look at a couple
of other things as we stand by for the
failed former president donald trump
let's see how newsmax is pitching it
all right welcome back
rob smith still technically my show but
we're warming you up for this big trump
rally tonight in wisconsin yeah so
ostensibly it was a great day for team
biden today right i'm sure you saw the
headline pop up our economy added 528
000 jobs oh let's see how they tear it
down it was more than double the 250 000
that economists were expecting true kind
of day biden dreams about because he
can't do anything right sounds like a
great number but there's something you
should know that is it is all a mirage
well we added 528 000 jobs in july there
were 136 000 fewer people participating
in the total workforce in may so how is
that possible well it appears
fewer people are working just one
full-time job
more americans now have multiple jobs
including part-time jobs republicans
used to say that that was good
the this is what you know i respect in
all seriousness i don't play games with
gas prices i don't play games with debt
and deficit and i don't play games with
jobs numbers
i respect all of you too much to do this
crap
these talking points are the exact
talking points that they used
before
reversed to talk about how great the
economy was they would say you know
what's great about this economy
it's the freedom to have one job or two
jobs or three jobs if that's what you
want the truth about this has nothing to
do with joe biden we are in a phase
where more people are retiring as a
result as a result
this is a reality about the labor force
participation rate baby boomers are
retiring that's just a thing also the
population continues to grow in the
united states so at almost any point you
can accurately say there's more people
than ever working right now
and there's more people than ever not
working right now both can be true
because the population keeps going up
these are pon scum
trash talking points that are beneath
every single one of you except maybe the
guy who said the thing about communism
okay so anyway we're gonna get off it's
unbelievable now if you want to see want
to see a hostage video i love this check
this out
maria bartoromo this morning
she
had i guess she does a business show so
it would be weird if she doesn't talk
about the jobs report
she looked like she was doing a forced
hostage video
i don't know if you've seen that famous
video where a pow a prisoner of war
is saying that he's being treated well
but he's blinking morse code for hostage
it's like this maria bartoromo seemingly
unable not to
give the report but she doesn't like it
headline here this is a blockbuster
report this is much higher than anybody
was expecting 528
000 jobs created in the month of july is
more than double the expectations which
called for job growth of 250 000. all
areas of the economy actually saw job
growth including leisure hospitality the
services industry the industrial
industry that's all good how is this a
problem for joe biden is what i want to
know good news the bad news this ensures
that we are going to see a federal
reserve that stays as aggressive as ever
the federal reserve will react to the
blockbuster job numbers by doing what
the federal reserve does when the jobs
market is very good this is a big big
problem yeah i know i know people are
joking in the chat is the jobs report
too good
that was what they did a month ago
they did they said is there so much work
that it doesn't leave enough dry powder
for the eco it was crazy
crazy the markets right now are pricing
in a 65
chance that the federal reserve raises
interest rates by and the market was
flat today like the market priced in
i'll show you
look at this whoops
finance yahoo oh god
check this out
the market priced in this disastrous
inevitability by having the s p down a
tenth of a point the dow up a quarter
point and the nasdaq down half a point
disturbing reaction from the market
pricing in this unbelievably disastrous
upcoming thing
with less than a half point move
in either direction
that doesn't sound that bad actually
by another 75 basis points in the next
meeting which is in september we are
waiting for the jackson hole event which
is where federal reserve officials
gather that will be newsworthy in the
coming weeks to find out how the fed
will deal with a jobs market that is
still generating growth and jobs uh now
the bad news how are we gonna i thought
it was all bad news maria what do you
mean now the bad news bad news is that
the federal reserve will continue
raising interest rates aggressively
that's going to make our borrowing much
more expensive and holding debt much
more expensive
it's like yes that's how the economy
works that's the role of the federal
reserve the these people are and again
the reason they can get away with this
stuff is because of who's watching maria
bartoromo if you want to learn anything
about finance you know what i mean
um unbelievable stuff johnny minogue
says via super chat i experienced
supreme shot and freud when i saw the
alex jones punitive judgment can't wait
for the infowars fire sale yeah if
you're looking what's that thing he
sells um
uh
the silver what's it what's the silver
liquid he sells anyway if you're looking
for a cut rate deal on the silver
drinkable silver it may be upcoming
lily of the valley says we're living in
the upside down absolutely absolutely i
want to say thank you to butch af clown
for life as well for the twitch prime
subscriptions folks uh you can sign up
for memberships at joinpakman.com
ben keefe just did exactly that and his
new member number 14 today also big
thank you to jason sickmeyer trevor
davis and our friend
juan for gifting subscriptions on the
website joinedpakman.com putting us at
17. the target is 100 if we get there i
will stream again tomorrow i will take a
weekend day off uh oh no i will take
a weekend day on
i will take off and off day
hmm i don't know the right way to
explain it anyway i would work tomorrow
and we would stream the trump cpac
closing speech if we get to a hundred
uh and i will not be taking any
colloidal silver during any of these
streams that i won't tease for you okay
sir i stole obama for my notification
tone so here's five dollars to
compensate also my 33rd birthday is this
weekend can i get a shout out you rock
absolutely danny here's a shout out
obama congratulations
david sir it's shocking that an eu
leader like orban would go to cpac to
spout trumpian catchphrases all the
while embracing praise from putin i know
it was it was downright dystopian
yesterday it really was and i mentioned
this on the earlier stream because today
is this is the second stream of the day
on the earlier stream i mentioned that
the biggest applause lines that cpac uh
this year
are um
transphobic and homophobic lines
essentially that's what's getting the
most
and then authoritarian uh tirades would
be next after that
and there was no shortage of
authoritarian tirades from a victor
orban
let's do a couple voicemails only
because i i just haven't
had a chance to play any voicemails it's
been so busy
did anyone catch that i don't know what
that person was saying
that's weird all right let's see if we
can find a voicemail
that is
substantive in some way
hi david this is about alex jones's
trial so i'm watching a watch mojo video
about 10 disturbing interviews with
killers
and one of them is like charles manson
from what i understand charles manson
may have killed one person but what he's
more famous for is this cult that would
terrorize
uh hollywood
how are you okay that's not exactly what
so oh my god
i just read an entire book about charles
manson by jeff guinn really good book i
recommend it
uh but this is not even the proper
framing of what charles manson did i'm
going to move on
i don't want to have to correct so many
different things
so let's let's move on a little bit
okay
you know
hello
yeah i'm fine
that's the stuff of nightmares that is
the stuff of nightmares
uh
let's see what else we've got today
david sir i just received an email from
your attorneys it's a 300 gigabyte file
containing information about the illegal
activity that happens during your bonus
show uh you have anything to say about
that thanks david bye well i'm not a
tech guy like alex jones said i ca i
really couldn't tell you anything about
that
uh but it means i was telling you the
truth uh i'm gonna have to fire my
attorneys that's for damn sure
let me see what else i've got for you
um
let's see what we have
actually don't have that much that's
interesting here for you necessarily
oh let's hear this one's from juan juan
gifts memberships regularly and
occasionally he has some interesting
questions hey david it's one here
i'm having a hard time uh
evaluating
what's
right wrong ethical unethical
etc when it comes to
the politics
in the united states
the only conclusion that i could come up
with for myself is
to really evaluate
what my
views are
to really think through
what i think is right and wrong because
basically what i'm trying to say is uh
yeah i can't
base my
decisions on
subjects
policies et cetera
i want most people think
okay juan we love you
we love the gifted memberships
that one i'm gonna have to move on from
and in fact i think i'm gonna have to
move on from voicemails because we're
hemorrhaging audience all of a sudden
thank you to texas bear claw
for the twitch prime subscription you're
number 18
also a huge thank you to katie welsh and
dana aguilar who just signed up at
joinpakman.com putting us at 20 and then
lastly a beautifully gifted membership
from martin phillian has come in and
that puts us at 21. all right let's
continue with some of the other things i
have here i don't know how many of you
saw this and we're gonna really need to
crank the audio level here
mike pillow spoke earlier today and he
is once again
unleashing a tirade against machines
we're doing a class action lawsuit
against all machines check out what
pillow had to say earlier today and this
is very important you hear me on this
over 54 countries have now been taken by
the machines
[Laughter]
they've been taken it's like when uh
it's like when the what was the name of
the bad terminator in terminator 2 was
like a t-1000 or what was the name of
the thing
what was the you guys know what i'm
talking about right what was the name of
the the tea
what was the the model of the terminator
2 machines
the t-1000
54 it sounds almost like he's saying
there's been like cyborgs that have
taken they've just the countries have
been taken that is something else and
this is very important you hear me on
this over 54 countries have now been
taken by the machines or are getting
shaken by the machines
this guy is a comedic genius it's it's
it's really something else
and you never get to go back
venezuela australia they're gone
these are these countries are over
thanks to the machines we're doing a
class action lawsuit against all
machines don't get to vote out the
machines once they're there once they're
there you don't get your country back
right the machines are not subject to
democracy small fuzzy moss you got to
grab that for the sound board that is
that is unbelievable
yeah beyond parody is right i i that
this guy is a comedic genius
despite himself i mean it's uh you know
he's not trying to be funny
that is an unbelievable clip
s prez
just gifted
50 subscriptions on twitch
pushing us all the way up to 71 s prez
thank you by the way
this might be a good moment to say
thanks to skittlestuh who is the number
one all-time gifter with 595 gifted
subscriptions on twitch
and uh that is an incredible number
thanks also to andy herr who is new
member number 50 72 today hey david it's
tyler from heller indiana
i recently called asking for your
opinion on if a trump descendant ticket
would be possible i don't think so
trump's furious with desantis because
desantis won't just rule out running if
trump is running
trump wants desantis to say if trump
wants it it's trump's and desantis
hasn't been willing to say that
partially because desantis actually has
a shot at beating trump in the primary
in 24. so i can't imagine there's going
to be a trump desantis ticket i don't i
don't see that at all at all
as even remotely likely open to hearing
other opinions
from people in the audience but i just
don't um
i i just don't see that
let's look at a couple of other things
here's another herschel walker clip i am
really quite taken in a sense with
herschel walker
from the standpoint of negative in that
he cannot speak he cannot explain his
position on anything
and yet
republicans easily made him the winner
of the georgia senate primary the thing
that's going on now is
he has sort of tricked some in the media
into thinking he plans to debate rafael
warnock and every time you hear him
explain something about the debate it
becomes clearer and clearer to me
that he has no interest in debating
whatsoever and here's another
explanation that is completely
unintelligible november are you going to
debate him
well i've called him on two debates he's
called him
on two debates
okay
i've called him on two debates he turned
me down on both of them because i said
what i want to do is see a fair and
accurate debate where it's for the
people not a fair and equitable debate
for the people
what does that mean like hit for his
fans i mean he's a politician he's not
he's not playing football anymore about
some press not about some party but the
people get a chance to see the
differences between my opponent and
myself where my opponent believed in
raising taxes during a recession right
but the question was are you going to
debate
what does it matter what his position is
on taxes my opponent believed being soft
on crime he voted with joe biden elect
officials that is soft on crime my
opponent believe that he voted to put
men in women's sports where i do he
voted that put men in women's sports
whatever the question was do you plan to
debate
i think men should be in women's sports
so there's a big difference in contrast
i think he's afraid to stand in front of
his georgia voters and stand up for the
record that he's voting that's a genius
move i have to say it's like herschel
walker's the guy who won't debate and
he's saying he thinks his opponent's
afraid to debate and what's genius about
it is
obviously herschel walker should not be
allowed by his handlers to debate like
his handler should be going you don't
want to debate
you can't put together a single coherent
thought
but
a trumpian move is just accuse your
opponent of being afraid to debate
and even if you're the one declining the
debates
say it's your opponent
just insist that it's your opponent uh
in a sense it's genius because it's
exactly the constituency that would fall
for it
people his followers would hear that and
they go raphael warnock won't debate
he
warnock won't show up and debate walker
what are you talking about yeah i heard
it from herschel himself he's not going
to show up
all right people asking when the rally
starts it was scheduled for five minutes
ago
so hopefully it starts very very soon
let's take a listen to what's happening
in wisconsin
let's go ahead and toss to a commercial
break if we can have master control
[Music]
at master control we'll go ahead and
toss
oh
[Music]
let's go ahead and toss our commercial
break if we can real quickly we'll get
some things situated on the ground
you're watching live coverage all right
so they're tossing so we'll go back over
here and stand by guys this venue is
packed
look at this crowd this could be uh
i think i see 60 000 people there
this has got to be the biggest crowd i
mean
ever maybe
okay
super chats can i get three obamas back
to back all right i guess so obama
obama
obama there you go
hope that did it for you i want to say
thanks to trella whitford who just
signed up at joinpackman.com
and martin phillian for gifting a
subscription
that puts us at 74.
also a big thank you to multibeast
and blueberry babe
for the twitch subscriptions putting us
at
76.
let's keep going i've got much more
material here here's something
interesting here's elon musk saying
something that i can actually very much
agree with listen to this you know if
the
president's working so hard to to sort
of free someone who's in jail in russia
for
some some weed then shouldn't we free
people america saw that
yeah yeah absolutely
in america for the same [ __ ] for the
same stuff shouldn't we free them too uh
it's something that's legal in so many
states right now
as well it's not i mean i i think it's
like for
it's not i mean my opinion is that
people should not be in jail for
non-violent uh drug crimes there you go
all right so elon musk making a lot of
sense hard to disagree with that let's
listen to mike pillow's new ad plus it's
certified organic and non-gmo i
guarantee it'll be the best coffee
you've ever had so go to mystore.com or
call the number on your screen use your
promo code and you'll get my copy for 25
off and i'm gonna give you deep
discounts on all my store products
that's mystore.com it's my new platform
for usa entrepreneurs please order now
okay
wow and the ad seems to have frozen
uh oh massive technical difficulties on
right side broadcasting look at this
it's completely frozen
yeah and it's not my just making sure
it's not my connection look at that
completely and totally frozen now
folks i want to say thank you to s prez
for gifting
another
50 subscriptions on twitch
also thank you
to
jen here and alice for gifting two more
putting us at 128.
folks let's go for 150 i know we can do
it thanks to deb patterson for signing
up on my website joinpakman.com
i absolutely love it we are moments away
from what will no doubt be a completely
dangerous and unhinged trump rally
in waukesha
wisconsin
it is criminal what we are going to see
tonight that i can almost assure you
almost assure you
the machines thing is scary my tractor
is on the warpath and headed for the
front porch save me uh oh the machines
have taken over at sherry's house that's
dangerous i don't like uncharged pickles
in my sandwiches do you i kind of prefer
jalapeno slices to be perfectly frank
terminator part 25 rage against the
machine starring mike pillow well said
very very much well said i think that
that's
perfectly accurate all right let's keep
going i have so many different things
for folks here
uh we did this let's see what other
clips we have from
the day from cpac and from different
things that are going on
uh let's see
oh this is pretty funny that's very
solid
that is that is good
i like that
look at how different he looks without
the 45 million you can really tell that
it's just a transformation
really a transformation that's that's
well done
um
lauren bobert says that pelosi is an
alcoholic literally you're the vodka's
evaporating from your skin you see it
coming out she says she doesn't drink i
don't believe that so uh you know glenn
beck asked me that um and i said you
know she says often she doesn't drink
which tells me she's drunk
yeah because any time my wife's going to
come nancy are you drunk
what did the drunk person say no
yeah the police whoa
uh the left had better be prepared for
the right getting good at comedy
because they're really coming for us
it's gonna be crazy
um
trump attorney christina bob says mega
women are hotter than liberals oh this i
have to hear you know the men on the
conservative side are alpha males they
drive big
oh god
big trucks you know they hunt they fish
the big trucks you know
the big truck guys i've told this story
before i know this won't be like new
ground for many of you
but as many of you know i drive an
electric vehicle
and it's much faster than any truck out
there just it just is it's not i'm not
there's nothing special about that it's
just it's just very fast
and um
i will notice often in uh
in parking lots i'll park far from the
door
for two reasons one
because i like the exercise i always
will take the stairs instead of the
elevator you should have seen me today
at the pediatrician
we got there and you've got to walk down
and upstairs or you can take elevators
and my girlfriend went to the elevator
and i said no no i'm taking we're taking
the stairs and she said sir are you sure
and i said absolutely i can get four
four flights in right here with carrying
the baby okay
and also
yeah that it's my i still see a
pediatrician exactly
and also i park far away from the door
because i do want to keep the car away
from i don't want the car getting
scratched up it's very common that i
will come out
and very far
next to my car there's no other cars
except an internal combustion engine
vial vial pickup truck right next to my
car
sometimes with the thin blue line
sticker
or whatever
and it's because the driver of that
truck needs me to know their genitals
are
huge
absolutely huge and that's what i think
also what will often happen is if i pull
up to a stop light in the electric
vehicle
a truck pulls up next to me and stops at
the red light
they will just peel out
leaving me in a cloud of exhaust
and then i go wow
that guy is just so cool and alpha in
every way and then i'm like i really
need to do that i guess you know so
anyway it's funny that she talks she's
seriously saying
that they drive the big trucks as if
it's actually something that
is good i mean it's crazy
i'm more interested in how quiet can my
car be like i find it interesting that
my car makes no noise
you know the men on the conservative
side are alpha males right and by the
way
and gas is so expensive
they drive big trucks you know they hunt
they fish they do all that and the women
love being women they know what a woman
is they know how to dress they know how
to act they take care of themselves and
as a result you have attractive women on
the conservative side right compared to
the women who are depriving you of any
opportunity to sleep with them brian i
know you were yeah i'm heartbroken right
now to be honest with you that you said
it i could not put it any better than
and i'm glad you said it not me but to
your point
uh
this is pretty serious political
analysis here yeah i mean you look and
just look at the
you know and i don't want this to sound
disrespectful at all right but when you
look at the the conservative women in
the movement right now yeah they're
beautiful i mean
marjorie taylor green incredible
incredible strong they're fit they
exercise carrie lake is a great example
great example of it and margie
okay i didn't know he was actually going
to say that in a serious way but that is
funny when instant grant with social
media she takes care of herself
versus a lot of the politicians on the
left look pasty like they've never gone
outside for an ounce of sunshine they
they don't eat any food or anything they
don't eat any food they just don't eat
any food they're not eating food they're
not uh yeah it's crazy all right so
that's that's crazy that's bonkers
what's going on there i want to say
thank you to bionic bill badest page
liquid ice chomp sui
cam 3 an anonymous gifter 1 2 3 4 5 6
six and 129 puts us at 135
and also a big thank you to martin
phillian for gifting a subscription
at
joinpackman.com what it these people are
truly beyond parody i mean be absolutely
beyond parody
haley from georgia with a super chat
shower thought is society more violent
and unhinged today because we have
stopped historically traditional warfare
where men are arbitrarily killing other
men rather than hellfire missiles
killing terrorists from afar
i don't know that i'm equipped to answer
that but i think there's probably a
guest who we could talk to about that
uh let me think about that that's kind
of interesting it's an interesting idea
oh let me mention another thing
i did i mentioned this before yeah i
think i did we are launching a personal
finance channel
and it is by popular demand we are
launching a new youtube channel i don't
have any link or anything else for you
yet
and we are getting dangerously close to
being ready to announce specifics and i
will show you a technical element
i have obtained
look at this
this is a think vision
um
tablet
monitor this is like a thing it's like a
it's a telestrator so with this i'm
going to be able to draw
charts and graphs and when people call
in with their personal finance questions
i'm trying to keep the light reflection
out of it i will be able to draw it this
thing is extraordinary from the reviews
i've seen i haven't even opened it yet
one thing i don't understand
the packaging is in english and russian
i've i'm used to getting products in the
us where the packaging is all in english
and spanish or english and french
this is the only technical element i've
ever had
where it's everything is in english and
russian and i have quite literally no
idea why if anybody knows why you know i
i'm curious to hear from you
uh okay
christina bob is now speaking to the
crowd
so good to see you
so i'm sure a lot of you have been on
truth social and you're aware that
all right well
i don't know that we're going to do that
truth essential yeah let's let's wait on
that so anyway the the new channel is
going to be launching soon and i think
it's going to be really great
i think it's going to be really great so
donald trump will be speaking soon
it looks like they're getting close to
something i don't really know
um
david why is it americans feel as if
we're getting more laws and restrictions
from the conservative movement when they
don't have power in washington but will
happen when they do get power
uh
let me think about that
let me think about that not totally sure
about that
okay let me mention once and once only
i would absolutely
love it
if you grabbed a membership on my
website joinedpakman.com in all
seriousness almost everything we do is
funded by these memberships we gladly
discount them these are criminal
discounts okay one of those discounts is
indict another one of the discounts is
obama
i'll even show you how to do this you
can do monthly or yearly
you save more
you can type in your coupon code here is
indict when you do that look at what
happens that is shocking i'm not even
going to say it out loud because it's
just too good if you want an even bigger
discount you type in obama obama
and then look at that
okay
we keep 98
of every dollar all of these other
platforms that you might support
creators on be it youtube twitch
facebook
roblox minesweeper
disc golf whatever
they are taking slice after slice after
slice okay
when you go to our website
98 cents on the dollar we keep we're
just swiping credit cards and i will
thank every single person who signs up
we have also just upgraded the
membership podcast experience thanks to
your recommendations and your support
we now have like an adult
member podcast before everybody was
sharing one password if you can think
about something more childish and
pathetic we now have a proper member
podcast you get email notification when
the member shows go up and the bonus
show of course you've got to get the
bonus oh the bonus show where you want
to make money everybody else that makes
money to find themselves is bad every
member gets their own rss feed so you
there's no sharing any passwords anymore
and you can put it in any podcast app
that you like of course if you'd rather
watch than listen you can do that as
well
it's arguably the major the biggest
upgrade we've done to the membership
program for a very very long time so the
point here is
i would love for you to sign up today at
joinpakman.com
that's where i will leave it indict is
one coupon code
obama
is another coupon code let's do it
let's do it
all right other uh oh let's do a couple
other voicemails just a couple other
voicemails let's see
what we've got
hey david uh i'm watching the live
stream right now and you mentioned that
uh
trump is furious with uh desantis
because uh defense isn't gonna just say
hey if trump wants a nomination it's his
so what happens if uh what do you think
is going to happen if it turns out to be
trump versus defenses in the primary and
maybe a couple other other lower tier
candidates yeah
but let's say the scientist you know
runs away with the nomination
and trump gets defeated
do you think there's a chance trump can
go and uh start like maybe a third party
god i hope so
that would be the dream that guarantees
a democratic blowout
if
trump loses the primary
and in a triggered tantrum decides to
run third party
he destroys
destroys the republican nominee
and it guarantees that the democrat wins
so
i don't pray but that's something i
could see praying for because that would
be absolutely fantastic
res rising says via super chat give me
your one word description of alex jones
i would say unhinged
is the the
best single word description i can think
of
alex jones punitive damage is 45 million
yep we covered it earlier quite a story
do you think trump will finally tell us
what he thought of the 2020 election i
mean it's been a few hours since the
last time he spoke about it my
prediction nick is that trump will
address the 2020 election
in today's uh
in today's speech yes i do think so i
want to say thank you to uncaged phoenix
who just made a twitch prime
subscription
also want to say thanks to bridger
lanning
and brett williams who just signed up on
my website joinpakman.com
pushes us to 139
and also thank you to jason sickmeyer
and juan
for gifting two more memberships putting
us at 141 folks we're almost at 150
um
let's
let's i guess listen a little bit to
this patriots and a lot more help is on
the way
but i grew up in a small town called
ripon wisconsin do you guys know ripon
ripon
ripon is famous for being the birthplace
of the republican party
but i'm sorry i have to make an
announcement
it's the birthplace of the old
republican party
the new republican party was born in
june of 2015 at trump tower in new york
city wow
and we must not go back to the days of
old
feckless cowardly republicans like paul
ryan
anybody know who this is robin vos
and george bush and dan crenshaw vote
the rhinos the hell out of office
the republican civil war is good for the
left the first fighters will fight for
you each and every day because president
trump taught them how to fight and how
to win and we're not going back
okay
and so without further ado
i want to introduce to you one of the
future leaders of the republican party
oh no my friend
america first patriot and candidate for
congress in ohio's ninth congressional
district j.r majewski oh i've
interviewed this guy he is completely
ignorant about almost everything get out
to vote for tim michaels for governor
adam steen for district 63. yeah uh i i
interviewed j.r majewski look at this
guy um we'll we'll deal with that in a
moment i want to say thanks to s prez
for gifting 10 more subscriptions on
twitch as well as prospect leveler which
puts us at 152. guys let's go for 200 as
we listen to j.r majewski
oh my buddies the front row joes
love the front row joes
good afternoon ladies and gentlemen i
want to give a special thank you to team
trump
and president trump for all of their
hard work inspiring us to wake up every
day and fight for this country
thank you team trump
and i know president trump's going to
hear us when he gets here
thank you to all of you for keeping when
he gets here he's already half an hour
late
my name is jeremy majewski and my
pronouns are patriot and ass kicker
mexico
if you don't know me
i'm the guy from ohio that decided to
turn his beautiful lake front property
into the world's largest trump 2020
banner
i know that his shirt says majewski but
all that's visible is the word jews
it's not exactly what i would be going
for and you would think someone would be
like jr it looks like your shirt says
jews and usually when people wear shirts
that say jews
they're not saying something good about
the jews you know i mean it's like how
did a campaign advisor not warn him
about that beauty ladies and gentlemen
like the great folks in wisconsin
governor michaels who's going to take
this state back
[Music]
i'm also proud to say that
i grew up in the worst neighborhood in
my district
blue collar family democratic family and
it wasn't until president trump came
down that escalator that my dad called
me and said this dude's going to kick
some ass son when he said the thing
about mexican rapists i just knew he had
upper management written all over them i
had my trump shirt printed the next day
[Music]
spent my career in the nuclear power
industry
and
worked very very hard started at the
bottom and worked my way all up to the
top and uh
i've dealt with some of the most
dangerous material known to men which is
spent nuclear fuel
and uh
starting in january oh i thought he
meant trump's toilet i think that's some
of the most dangerous material on on
earth a crazy idea says nexter but maybe
the thinkpad was slated to be sold in
russia and diverted due to sanctions
that's interesting
andrew says congrats on the baby love
your show brother wish i could offer
more andrew thank you for your support i
really appreciate that i know many of
you are noticing this gentleman right
here uh this gentleman is
at most trump rallies i know there are
questions about who he is and what the
deal is and is he part of blacks for
trump or whatever he was indeed at the
anchorage alaska rally i don't really
know who he is but he's at every he's at
just about every rally
um
and i don't i don't really know
too much else quite frankly
folks i can't thank enough all of the
people signing up on my website look at
these names kimberly lock is a new
member dan rapson just signed up
kailyn gottman is a new member
becca king has signed up mark ballard
and chris wright are new members
janice johnson is a new member one two
three four five six seven folks
which we love
that puts us at 159 if my math serves
and then thanks to samantha orman
uh
kevin john
johnny minogue another gifted membership
from kevin john and mark fillion
that's five pushes us to 164
as j.r majewski just will not stop
speaking and getting people out of the
way and we're going to have a congress
that's going to do something and imagine
how much is going to get done by
president trump when he has people that
are loyal to him
that's right i'm a fire starter folks if
you haven't heard about me check me out
j.r majewski the number four
congress.com
i'll leave you with all of this please
as a veteran i used to wake up every day
willing to risk my life for what i
thought this country stood for
and i've been fighting every day
during this election cycle
and i've woken up every day
wondering
how much i'm going to have to risk and
whether or not it's going to be my life
to save my family what my friends
and our country
from what it's become
anyone know why we he he would have to
risk his life to save his family what's
he talking about
i don't know what he's saying you have
to be built
from steel have to be built
from steel a little chubby
to do it
you got to love this country and we do
we need your support every one of you
out there
the trump train train is running hot if
you got big shoulders like me grab a
shovel because it needs a lot of coal
number of metaphors though
my primary election was tough
i mentioned my father
a minute ago i'll tell you that my
father passed away right before my
primary election
and um
i won't get emotional up here because
alex just said that politicians don't
cry on tv
um but my father loved president trump
my mother loves president trump i love
president trump you love president trump
and the country loves him
i love all of you in return god bless
you god bless wisconsin
and god bless
the united states of america
and to my wife at home i love you dearly
sweetheart
and god bless
the united states
yeah so anyway check out my interview
with him he
really struggled with very simple
questions
very very simple questions and he was
struggling to answer them
thanks to maddened
beta zoid and al topek
for the twitch prime subscriptions
putting us at 167.
also thank you to new members on my
website joinpakman.com
mark allen shane maguire monica butler
barbara carroll and jill mabley folks
the ladies are so strongly represented
in membership during live streams it's
very interesting shows like mine have a
male leaning audience overall
but during the live streams
the ladies just come out of the woodwork
with the memberships they're really
coming through and i appreciate it very
very much
um trump's a half hour late now so we'll
probably only have a couple hours to go
until he shows up
maybe a few minutes behind
due to weathers as we know that there is
no other you know you got a safety first
when you're flying obviously as you can
see
extremely dangerous weather there in
waukesha
waukesha
wacrisha wisconsin
uh they may or may not be able to land
visibility is almost zero there and it's
very clearly the reason for the delay
will you be live tomorrow for the
reconciliation bill in the senate
probably not tomorrow i do have a busy
day but if anything i will be covered
now i'm good i'm going to cover the um
because we we've got our goal i'm going
to cover the trump cpac speech in the
evening
all right thank you to manny aj4 and
joseph rader for the twitch prime
subscriptions
they are trying to land trump's plane
but as you can see the weather may
really make that difficult in wisconsin
today
going to be very very tough
let's see if we can listen to a couple
of other voicemails hey david this is
dave in california
let's say they convict donald trump
no judge
is going to want to make them do hard
time
of course so this is what his punishment
should be
he should never say the election was
stolen again
he should say that president biden was
duely elected president of the united
states yeah i don't know that you can
like compel speech as a punishment i'm
just i'm just not
sure about that
hey david this is max from connecticut
watching the live stream right now i was
wondering when they call him president
trump
is that normal or is that election lie
delusions to call a former president
okay
let me answer this so there's two
different things and i know that there's
people in the audience who are
divided about this so let me explain it
to you
when you speak to a president
okay
even if they are former president
they still have the title of pres of mr
president
okay when you when you are speaking to a
president
in general
media outlets would say former president
trump okay so like when cnn mentions
obama for example
they say former president obama as a
general thing
so it and this is why people get
confused because people say no but you
always refer to a president as president
yes that's interpersonally
you would say mr president you're right
it's sort of like do you still refer to
hillary clinton as madam secretary that
was the highest position that she came
to achieve in government
but you don't say secretary of state
hillary clinton you would you could say
former secretary of state hillary
clinton
so um
anyway yeah that's that's the deal
it's almost pitiful hearing these
political figures at rallies praising
trump as he's running late when they
have to know being laid is one of many
signs he couldn't care less about these
people emphasis on almost absolutely
trump doesn't care about these people
you all know that
you know it
i know it
we all know it a little off east in the
great state the commonwealth of
pennsylvania you've got doug mastriano
uh easily winning his primary going up
in the general now if you want to look
at the three with the three of the five
swing states
that we must win in 2024 yep okay so
there this is what right side
broadcasting is doing on newsmax they're
talking to dick morris let's see what
kind of stuff he's saying my friend no
she's a former bartender so she's
sensitive to being proofed
hey she knows what it takes to ask for
an id right maybe she'll bring back a
voter id dick always appreciate your
time
thank you
all right guys take a look again there
it is they're waiting on the president
he'll be there imminently he's going to
talk he's going to speak my guess and
again this is just my guess i think
we'll have a lot to do with crime the
last time he spoke in dc he talked a lot
about crime
i think he will something very very near
and dear and heartbreaking for the
people of wisconsin when they lost so
many people at that parade when the man
the terror oh my god
look at what is happening here it is it
is wild absolutely wild
thanks to mavis carroll
kelly dot and broken psyche for the
twitch prime subscriptions putting us at
178 i think we may hit 200. chance
alberts and medi are
as well as
alex
civic
have all just signed up on my website
putting us at 181
and then thanks to a gifted subscription
from martin phillian
we are now breaching
182.
let's check out um a couple of other
clips here
from the day it's just been a crazy day
here's ted cruz apparently at his cpac
book signing
with
the trump cheerleaders i guess uh
i guess they are okay it's sort of weird
here are people yelling i love you
marjorie at cpac
so quite a commotion happening at cpac
there
oh oh god hold on here's another video
of hershel walker again explaining how
he wants to debate senator warnock
next star media group offered to host a
debate for us in savannah
on october 14th in front of the people
don't be scared
i know you rejected previous offers i
made
but please consider this one
this debate is more than fair to you
and it's for the people
it's in your own backyard savannah
notice that he says the same thing in
every one of these videos and we never
know what he's talking about we have
hometown advantage
it's been hosted by a respected
third-party media group with multiple
outlets in georgia
it would be aired statewide on broadcast
television in prime time
so everybody will get a chance to watch
it
is a prime time showdown in savannah
you know i'm
in come on raphael let's do this
for georgia yeah i'm actually gonna make
a note of this
because on monday i'm thinking about
doing a segment
about how weird it is that he's now kind
of acting like
warnock's the guy who doesn't want to
debate it's all absolutely bizarre
uh very strange folks we just got a 20
community subscription gift on twitch
from
and graveborn has gifted 50 memberships
on youtube that's 70. okay let me see if
i can do the math 182 plus 70.
you've got 2 and 0 that stays as 2.
eight and seven is fifteen so i know the
middle number has to be a five
and with one
i've gotta carry
what was it wait hold on fifteen oh so
i'm carrying a 1.
so is that 252
i think that that's it guys
let's go for 300.
i think we can do it nannermom and
counting amberjacks as well as melissa
and poutine
have just signed up via twitch putting
us at 256. speaking of poutine
i have to admit
i've started dabbling in pork products
again no no pork loin or anything like
that
but the other day i had a beautiful
prosciutto with melon
and
i am soon going to be very much inside
of montreal
i predict there may be poutine in my
future
it's completely conceivable that there
may be poutine in my future
and i know that that's going to come as
a shock to a lot of people
a lot of people
thanks to brenda needleman as well as
nav deep singh and denise roland who
just signed up on my website
joinpackman.com
also shauna blackburn
and trevor davis dropping in two
subscription gifts which i be will be
able to give away if you want a free
membership along with everything that
comes with it go to davidpakman.com free
membership
you we we're going in order
but you can request a free membership
at davidpakman.com
free membership yes of course in
montreal i'm going to go to schwartz
schwartz's deli
uh and i will go to saint via tour bagel
i'm going to be all over the place all
of the good uh the good jewish spots i
will be there
um
yeah no it's gonna it's gonna be very
very solid very solid
if trump runs on a third party he might
attract other trumpist republicans to
the ticket further destroying the
republican party oh i know john
trump running third party would be
absolutely fantastic
the person you referred to behind trump
is maurice simonette blacks for trump
founder he was part of the nation of
yahweh cult in the 80s 90s charged with
involvement in two murders but acquitted
well
allegations are not proof let's put it
that way
let's put it that way
the food is fantastic in montreal
absolutely
absolutely
let's see what else we have here oh
thanks to candy crow candy crow just
signed up at joinedpakman.com
a lot of people confused as to what
counts here okay towards 300.
three things count towards the 300
number actually four okay number one is
you sign up on my website joinpakman.com
very easy
join pacman.com
second thing that counts is any kind of
twitch subscription be it prime meaning
bezos bucks or
direct
it all counts
three
youtube gifted subscriptions
and four
patreon pledges count double so any
pledge at patreon.com david pakman show
counts as not one but two
because two is twice one and that's what
what i mean when i say they count double
other super chats david sir this is the
best voice of reason i listen to
and get as much poutine as you can in
montreal yeah
i mean listen i'm not going to go crazy
it's not like i have poutine daily in
montreal
but it's been a long time since i've had
poutine
and i've been to montreal it must be 20
times
and
we're looking at poutine very strongly
and other culinary elements
other culinary elements very important
stuff
we are supposedly moments away from
donald trump speaking they've brought
out a guy with a huge mustache on
newsmax which to me says it must be
imminent
it must be absolutely imminent that
donald trump is going to speak
let's listen well when you cross
president trump and you try to take on
donald trump don't do it i'm just saying
especially when the american people have
president trump's back as they should
have his back because he has our back
that's it from day one he did remember
they're not coming for him
they're coming for you and that's all
president trump did was standing away
from that a couple minutes away before
we toss it over to tudor dixon and
carrie lake who are live at cpac dowsers
by the way we will continue our coverage
tomorrow morning from dallas here we go
let's take it to speakers
for a special live broadcast from our
friends on the ground at cpac the
conservative political oh my god is
trump running so late that they're just
showing cpac at the trump rally this is
crazy
this is nuts
no audio
and we will ban
men
hello wisconsin i want you all to know
that president trump sees you he sees
your beautiful faces he hears that
roaring crowd and he is so excited to
get to y'all in waukesha wisconsin
tonight that is a great look 2022
president trump is on his way to you he
cannot wait to see y'all tonight but
before he gets there we want to bring
you some guests live here in dallas so
without further ado i would like to
bring in the future governor of arizoca
the american arizona
miss carrie lake
congratulations kerry
oh my goodness
hello hello wisconsin how are you doing
i got to tell you wisconsin is one of my
favorite states i'm from iowa i grew up
the youngest of nine children in iowa
and my parents were from wisconsin this
is completely nuts in case you can't
tell i lived in wisconsin and i spent a
lot of summers in wisconsin it's such a
beautiful state and i'm so excited about
this amazing race you have what on earth
is arizoca i mean that is bizarre what
the hell
it just
they can never just do it normally
arizoca a good governor saved us
protected our freedom and a bad governor
locked us up forced us to get shots we
didn't want masked our children shut our
businesses down and some governors even
shut our churches down and we know that
we can't have that anymore and that's
why it's so important to get out and
vote and we just had an amazing election
in arizona i'm so proud of what the
people of arizona accomplished what our
campaign accomplished we have returned
the republican party to we the people
it's the party of lincoln it's the party
of reagan and of course we know it is
the party of donald j
trump let's hear it for president trump
and now the republican party is the
party of we the people and it's so
exciting because people are waking up
really generating an electric atmosphere
huh they're waking up to the dead end
policies and how they destroy our
businesses hurt our families and frankly
hurt our health and so i think it's
really exciting that we're welcoming
people into the republican party right
now and i believe that we will grow this
party into the party that truly does
represent all kinds of people former
democrats former independents if you
love america if you love freedom if you
want to see common sense policies put in
place that restore our freedoms and make
sure that we have safe streets once
again and we have an economy where we
can prosper then you need to join our
movement and it's such an exciting
movement i want to tell you
when president trump endorsed me let me
see it was a little over about a year
ago okay anyway so that's carrie lake
and she's cuckoo for coco puffs uh it's
so this is all bizarre i mean trump
trump must be running so late
that they're having to run interference
uh it's all very odd espress asks isn't
trump running late to your financial
advantage well i guess we'll find out
wendy says okay i gotta say something
trump has never had anyone's back ask
his daughter he just threw her under the
bus ask rudy he dropped rudy like a hot
rock he has never had anyone's back it's
more wendy
trump spent most of his life trying to
stay away
as a rich new york city dude from the
very people that he now depends on for
financial support and that he depended
on for votes and that he will depend on
for votes
if he is to run again
so it's actually even worse than that
thank you to god speed
and the thogler
for the twitch prime subscriptions
putting us at 264. also thanks to ben
and jen baskerville
signing up at joinpacman.com with the
coupon code obama
new member number 265 today appreciate
that
espress says trump is running so late he
will be competing with saturday night
live i know tomorrow night at the rate
it's going
thanks to roy ann weimers or weirdners
no weimers
thank you so much for the subscription
at joinedpakman.com very much appreciate
it your new member number 266
today
let's do a couple more voicemails yeah
people asking for the voicemails let's
see what else we have here
hey david so i'm really concerned i just
arrived at the airport here in australia
and it looks like it's just a bunch of
ti 30 xs's
such a
is that a
is that an espresso machine
okay all right
fumbled it a little bit but i get it i
sort of get it
um all right let's listen to another
voicemail hey david mike from oregon
long time watcher uh long time watcher
um
so i wanted to ask you a question i
don't know if you've heard the uh like
recent debate going on uh in terms of
like uh
the end goal uh for conservatives right
now with all the anti-lgbt stuff
like what is their ultimate end goal uh
destiny
bonnell jr the second or whatever
and uh vaush uh have been debating it
well not debating it directly but
destiny's been reacting to
vaush's videos pretty much [ __ ] all
over the concept
that um there
that
uh conservatives would are pushing
essentially for a genocide
because if you break everything down and
you think about what is the end goal
what do they want
you know with all the dehumanizing
calling people groomers you know
essentially all this stuff they're
taking it to the extreme
and it doesn't seem like there's any
stop in in sight and what is what would
the conclusion of that extremity uh you
know
be so yeah i think it's just to
continually have enemies
to to fundraise on the basis of oh look
pillow is speaking i had some plane
problems i'm stuck here at cpac which
integrate in a bad place to me it's been
awesome here
um how about uh it's getting a little
harder for them to cover up the biggest
crime in history isn't it after what
happened now in arizona they tried to
steal it from kerry lake they stopped
the machines in the middle of the night
does that ring a bell
disgusting absolutely disgusting
but we're gonna we are going it just
shows carries a good reason or it
happened for a reason it shows you that
you can override the algorithms you can
get out and vote and vote in person vote
in person everybody don't take those
mail ballots to vote in person remember
she was 10 points behind by 11 o'clock
at night then all of a sudden she's up
by 12 000 votes and they go shut it down
shut it down i mean it's just disgusting
what they're doing the machines have to
go machines have to go they have to be
gone forever in our country i'm gonna
have a summit i want to tell you all
about it everybody you can watch it on
frank's speech on august 20th and 21st
this is going to change our country's
history we're going to have all 50
states there up on stage people that
have worked hard for our country and for
our great president donald trump i want
you know this is all about communication
too we get through all this i mean look
at that look at right now
with your true social and and you guys
should all get on that too we have to
communicate everybody we have to get the
hope out the word out we are winning and
it's so exciting what happened in
arizona all of the all the american
first candidates all that um
president trump's endorsements i mean
they've all come true and uh it's been
absolutely amazing i wish um
with all of you too i want to say to not
sit there and uh we all got to be
courageous at this time we're in a
perfect time in history the absolute
perfect time where we're going to look
back and we're going to say god's had
his hand in all of this everything had
to happen just the way it did right just
think if uh um and by the way i'm going
to tell you how we're getting our
country back
is the judges remember our great
president appointed over 300 judges
three supreme court judges and you know
what a year and a half ago
none of them looked at any evidence none
of them did because they had i believe
they had fear they have families they
have friends families grandchildren and
they didn't want to be the first one he
just does not stop and jumping
uncontrollably from one topic to another
but you think of this
now the judges have slowed the
destruction of our country imagine being
in line all day to go to a trump rally
and then they just play a video of
pillow the great decision to say these
masks are nonsense and these mandates on
airplanes changed our course of history
how about the supreme court
reverse and roe v wade i mean this is
they got brave they went out there with
the judges they were appointed to be
we've got so many judges how about the
hundred if you have a hundred people in
your company you have to get a shot um
that that got shoved down by a judge so
judges are looking at things i want to
tell everybody in arizona remember the
preliminary injunctions were doing
across the country to get rid of the
machines the first one was arizona who
was the plaintiff carrie lake and mark
fincham this is what the people want and
that judge in arizona he was the first
one he said you know what i'm gonna look
at that how many topics has he touched
on so far no segue whatsoever
well he looked at it and he hasn't made
his decision yet but at least he looked
at it i want to tell you about these
machines i'm going to give you a good
example that happened over in georgia
terrible over in georgia on may 24th
there were three three democrats running
in a primary well this nice lady and her
husband woke up and they had zero votes
in their own pri in their own precinct
zero so old crooked brad rasenberger had
to go see what are we going to do we
should have gained at least two i like
that and uh so they did what did they do
they looked inside the machines
and they found three thousand seven
hundred and some votes which made her go
from third i opened up that machine
and i went eye to eye with it
and i saw pure evil on the ballot and
then rasenberger called it it was a
programming error with the machines he
won his own race 38 he was pulling out
the next day he gets 51 of the vote this
is the corruption that's going on with
these machines and uh we are going to
get rid of them all they're going to be
gone but until they're all gone by
getting out and everybody voting on
election day we can override the
algorithms and have great candidates get
into power because other ones have let
us down politicians have let us down
woman quite frenetic right now uh tudor
dixon and she's the nominee for the
governor of michigan against you know
who the horrible governor this here
thank you so much thank you wow hello
wisconsin i'm so jealous of you right
now because
i'm here and you get to see president
trump in just a few minutes that's so
exciting uh excuse me tudor that's a few
hours please let's not overstate it
thanks to the blah
for gifting five subscriptions via
youtube thanks to kahali as well as lark
and load
and blurred cube as well as periphery
for the twitch prime subscriptions
putting us at 275 folks we may get to
300
because i also want to say thanks to
claire light robin dopp
navdeep singh
and sarah frazier
with four website memberships at
joinpakman.com
a gift from martin fillion
as well as another new subscriber named
andrew mcewen
which puts us at 281 ladies and
gentlemen
oh and s prez just dumped in another 20
memberships folks
that puts us at 301
why don't we go for 350
i mean it seems almost criminal
but i think we have to do it you can
override the algorithm did he just admit
carrie lake's campaign interfered with
the machines it sounds like it no he
means by voting if you vote enough
you can override the machines
that's what he meant
reminds me of zoolander bit where they
destroy the computer
yeah i'm getting ready to destroy some
machines i've got an extra microphone
right here that i'm not even using this
thing's not on it's just a backup in
case there was an emergency
i'm thinking of destroying this machine
i don't know we're doing a class action
lawsuit against all machines you know i
think i accidentally broke it so now i
don't even have to destroy it
i'm not sure that mike pillow knows what
an algorithm is oh he has no idea what
it is
there's not even a chance it isn't fair
it isn't right mr trump screamed and
then they were upon him
right
thanks for the super chat ron very much
appreciate that as well and thanks to
tanya skinner for signing up at
joinpakman.com your new member number
302
putting us within striking distance of
an incredible number
350.
um all right let's look at a couple
other clips before we get back to that
let me see what else we've got actually
let's refresh to see what new stuff we
have here
trump spokesperson suggests the fbi is
covering up the identity of the pipe
bomber i don't think that's true right
and you know the real telling thing is
the the pipe bomber they're referring to
the january fifth slash sixth pipe
bomber who left pipe bombs at the dnc
sham on select committee
uh is very uncurious about this whole
uh so-called pipe bomber as well and
this is one thing that they refuse to
talk about
because they're hell-bent
on stopping my boss president donald j
trump and our political movement i mean
just ask dick cheney in his awful creepy
weird
uh final closing argument for his
daughter
in wyoming
saying explicitly this is her sole
mission and that's the sham
uh committee's mission it's not the
truth and if they wanted the truth they
claim this is you know the biggest
attack and threat to democracy
ever wouldn't they want to know exactly
what was going on with something that
you know ostensibly would have caused
the most she sounds completely wasted i
don't know what the hell she is talking
about
it is completely bizarre
uh
let's see what else we've got here
i guess that's kind of it we're caught
up there as far as clips go which is a
which is a very good thing
[Applause]
wow
every network unclear how much longer
this is going to go on david mckee says
what does donald dump call ted cruz's
beard
i have no idea
i genuinely have no idea
uh
a lot happening here that's for sure
thanks to rachel dreamer as well as
cindersole for the twitch prime
subscriptions appreciate that very much
also gifts coming in from andrew avr
drums
as well as laurie cadezoni
that's three gifted subscriptions
putting us at 307
and then welcome to andre philippe saint
arnaud
as well as kyle gilbert
signing up at jointpakman.com new
members 308 and 309
it's al gore rhythms
al gore rhythms
interesting
it's really sad when i agree with
anything dick cheney or his family say
where has our country gone oh
i saw that clip let's actually look at
that that's a good clip let me see if i
can find it
dick cheney
trump coward
it was basically spot on let me see if i
can find it here
yep check this out
here's the latest from dick cheney not a
guy i ever imagine i would agree with in
our nation's 246-year history there has
never been an individual who is a
greater threat to our republic than
donald trump true
true
he tried to steal the last election
using lies and violence to keep himself
in power after the voters had rejected
him absolutely he he's a coward a real
man wouldn't lie to his supporters he
lost his election and he lost big
i know it he knows it and deep down i
think most republicans know it
lynn and i are so proud of liz for
standing up for the truth doing what's
right honoring her oath to the
constitution when so many in our party
are too scared to do so
liz is fearless she never backs down
from a fight there is nothing more
important she will ever do
then lead the effort to make sure donald
trump is never again near the oval
office
and she will succeed
i am dick cheney i proudly voted for my
daughter i hope you will too
i'm liz cheney and i approve this
message
any time you see a video of dick cheney
you sort of need the imperial march but
he's completely correct
absolutely and completely correct he's
in his 80s now
and uh has at least stumbled across one
accurate statement that's something
it's at least something you know hard to
uh
hard to beat them
uh okay
couple other voicemails let's see what
we got here
hey david it's tommy in wisconsin you
mentioned earlier last week that all
these packet groups are paying trump's
legal bills who's paying his water bill
if he's squashing his toilet 10 to 15
times the taxpayers
the taxpayers quite frankly
hey david um
long time viewer calling i'm wondering
if you've seen
the
a trend on tick tock where people debate
each other they go on live and they host
debates about political views abortion
for example
it's a very popular topic
um the debates are often
crazy and but it's really interesting
because you see
[Music]
just the wild things that people believe
so i'm just wondering if you've seen any
of that
by the way i thought trump is late
because they had to clean ketchup off
the airplane wall that could be the
explanation that could be let's see if
they're still talking about the weather
as the reason trump's late the greatest
president this generation has known and
i i don't think the shame and fear that
the left is settling is working anymore
it's not working and i and christina i
remember back in 2008 pope and change
barack obama and the way they demonized
the american flag and and and really
vilified anybody that had some
patriotism and i remember thinking to
myself one day
you're going to look at the american
what planet are these people living on
john says via super chat david keep up
the good work thank you john i
appreciate that very much
very very much
let's see what else we have from the
standpoint of
super chats
hey david it's peter from texas again i
just had one question for you
um
who was the first person you voted for
and why did you vote
i think i voted for my friend greg for
um school
president in high school was the first
one but
in like legal votes 18 plus
who would that have been
i guess it would have been
um
2002.
i guess it would have been the 2004
presidential election
voting for
uh
john kerry
i think
i mean i probably voted in some local
election
but i don't
i don't exactly remember yeah that's
weird that i don't remember
i guess it didn't make much of an
impression on me to some degree
hi david i was watching the alex jones
trial clips and enjoying them and i was
fantasizing about trump being in the
same situation i know oh god that would
be so amazing
thank you yeah i mean if you put trump
under oath it would go about as well as
it went for alex jones
it would be similar in that sense
let's see
what else we have here
so what i don't get
is that
when you go to therapy
and it's like oh
well
in the eyes of a therapist if you're
thinking about murdering people and it's
like this enjoyable feeling
it's like really really wrong
but when you're an actual murderer
and you murder people
and then go through all the correct
emotions it's not sick
and then they're telling people oh well
when we have an appropriate vocabulary
word for things that we agree on that
like oh well everybody just happens to
think about murdering people
or maybe it's normal to think about
murdering people in a certain situation
that they're right
so basically what it boils down to
is that
when
god thinks about
killing people he's like
laughing or
you know this is good this is right
when god murders people or when he
tortures people and that kind of stuff
it's like you know an enjoyable thing
for the lord
and then when somebody is like human
it's like no but you have a body and so
you're like
you know
incapable
of actually murdering somebody and like
getting away with it
that's sick
when you
or that's not sick when you can
think about murdering people and it's
like
really funny and like an enjoyable
thought in your head then that's sick
so what it really really boils down to
is like these [ __ ] fat white [ __ ]
just want to worship black [ __ ] okay
and we're done we are moving on to
something different here dear god that
took a turn oh my god that that came out
of nowhere that completely came out of
nowhere from whitney uh wow wow wow wow
explosive allegations being made today
um that's crazy
i don't know how the conclusion follows
from the premises to be perfectly frank
uh
that that's just beyond me wow the chat
just went crazy
chat just went nuts because of that
i i've never i i just i don't i'm not
following it sequentially the internal
logic of it is beyond me to some degree
big daddy says david if you reach 400
new members it'll be so criminal roger
stone will defend you in a press
conference well said
well said
have you referred whitney to the
authorities yet now might be a good time
yeah
exactly
uh you're not wrong you're not wrong
thanks to andrew avr drums for gifting a
subscription and thanks to paul hardin
for subscribing himself that puts us at
311. folks we are within striking
distance of 305
new memberships today c missile
just signed up on twitch which puts us
at 3 12.
what an incredible day to have all of
you here
they can't get people to accept their
green new deal and their crazy
globalist policies on their own because
they're not good for this nation they're
not good for the american people so
they're trying to do it in a way that's
forced compliance and they're doing it
by raising gas prices so that americans
feel that they have to shift to electric
oh she's pulling the hole
they
are deliberately making gas more
expensive
and now they're deliberately making it
cheaper too now many many states have
already completed their primaries and
they're just bringing in more more
patriotic candidates you said a word a
few moments ago forced compliance that's
what they want and that's what they kind
of achieved during the the lockdowns of
2020 with with covet and the mass
mandate yeah everybody was really
complying guys that's uh that's exactly
what was happening
danny says whitney's logic is equivalent
to that of a derailed train
please search twitter marjorie taylor
green praying cpac oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah there was this really weird thing
let me see if i can find it
marjorie taylor green
there was this oh i'm not finding it
hold on a second
where was it
oh i'm unable to find it yeah no i i'll
look at it for monday i'll look at it
for monday i just i'm struggling to find
it right now
yeah i don't know where it is
okay
hey david
i think that uh alex
hold on i can't actually legitimately
i'm reading the trans yeah i can't play
that voicemail well i just avoided a ban
on every platform we're on
by reading ahead to the transcription of
that voicemail and not playing it
we almost would have just completely
gotten shut down which would not have
been good
um the sun is literally setting on this
crowd i know it is it is quite literally
setting
it's important if this is a painful
process for you most americans and you
are in need of employment go work at
your county election office
make sure that the elections are secure
i think we're seeing people do that in
record numbers in ways that we haven't
seen before it's so important thank you
to all the patriots out there
volunteering at their local elections
and that is going to be what changes
this nation
while we're on thanking people i'm going
to thank our moderators right now
over at right side we've got a team of
people christina behind this camera
we've got three cam ops here that are on
the ground here and it's been a long day
here in wisconsin let me tell you it's
hot a lot of equipment we're moving
around we're on this media riser running
around trying to get all these shots
maintained so we want to thank our
camera operators on the frown we want to
thank our guys over at master control
that are behind the computers switching
the show putting up the graphics on the
bottom sounds like they're using
machines traders that
are there in these chat rooms to keep
the communication flowing and to really
you know make sure that no one gets out
of control and says something
inappropriate because we do promote free
speech
there's some trolls in there and the
trolls aren't really bothered as much as
the people that just have a lot of hate
but we want to thank our entire team
right now we've had two
really long events today and cpac you
know liz willis vanessa broussard alex
caldwell they they have been at cpac all
day in the last two days and then of
course we've been out here so it's been
a long day and we just want to thank
everybody uh for really hanging in there
and getting us through this and i think
that was a beautiful pre-program that we
saw earlier and we and it's our pleasure
to be able to provide that for for save
america president donald j trump yeah
absolutely i think it's great and i
think i think the american people love
it and i think they love seeing you know
the crowd and even though we're slightly
delayed a little bit i think for the
most part people are okay with it
we're slightly delayed up close and
they're just kind of enjoying the show
so yeah trump's 75 minutes late and
they've been filling by having people at
cpac talk to the crowd donate we are
viewer supported we've got great
patriots like mike lindell but we're
very much supported by people like you
that have brought us from these very
humble beginnings of having yeah well
listen guys i'll give you the option you
can either support right side
broadcasting
uh or you can support our programming
you can use the coupon code indict
or you can use the coupon code
obama at joinpakman.com these coupon
codes are not
uh unlimited there could be a run on
these coupon codes and we could run out
of them
and so i'm thrilled to see
stephen gagnon
sign up at joinpackman.com and become
member 313
i'm thrilled to see our good friend from
tokyo kyoko awaya gifting a subscription
and sherry bailey as well two gifted
subscriptions on the website putting us
at 3 15
and kyoko sending another gift kyoko's
great kyoko calls into the show
and she
kyoko actually if you missed her last
phone call in
kyoko admitted that despite
um living in japan being japanese she
believes i am better at making miso soup
than she is
which was a pretty
controversial but also seminal moment
certainly in my life
to be told that
so that was very very exciting and i
always appreciate uh
kyoko's gifted subscriptions
blueberry says that was insane please
have a super chat yeah the whitney
voicemail it was crazy david what do you
think about a donald trump's start time
prediction i propose starting now 15
minutes seem fair i.e
9 30 over under i tried donating from
twitch but it seems it didn't go through
all right yeah let's do it
moderators on twitch please get a
prediction going or a poll will it be
will the start time be before or after 9
30 pm eastern time i'm gonna get one
going on youtube
when will
trump speech begin
and i will put
before 9 30 pm eastern
before 9 30 pm
eastern
or after 9 30 p.m eastern
okay
and then we can do the same thing over
on
twitch
and the question will be the same before
9 30 p.m eastern
after 9
30 p.m eastern and we will start it
let's see what people think
on youtube
92 of you believe that trump will be
later than 9 30 p.m eastern
on twitch
uh wait where's my poll
current poll here it is
93 of you believe that it will be after
9 30. okay now it's settling down a
little bit
now it's settling down a little bit
but that was some pretty lopsided
voting there for a bit
uh no on youtube 92 of you still believe
trump will be later than 9 30.
and on twitch about 93 of you yeah so
people seem to be pretty sure
he's not starting in the next 13 minutes
that that may very well be the case
interesting
he might not start till 11 pm well i'll
be gone in that case if that's the case
i'll be i'll be long gone
all right so but most of you seem pretty
confident this is not starting by 9 30
which is certainly
reasonable given the circumstances i
think that that that's completely and
totally reasonable let's listen to a
couple of other voice mails as they're
coming in here
d d g
d d g
g g d d g g
g d g e
m
hi david and friends um this is
cassandra in beautiful san diego and
i've been meaning to call i love your uh
covering the debates and trump
especially i've never missed one trump
speech because you always have to keep
the eye
on the uh
we're not enemies but you know anyway
i've thought about this for a while now
i was going to call remember on the
apprentice when trump
always matched at least half of what the
um
you know the the sponsor was doing
what a scam i bet he never came through
on any of that kind of one i remember he
had a trust
um that he the other charities
they were putting in well anyway i'm
rambling on so i wanted you to think
about that uh i think that's quite plus
one more thing i always think about
is you remember when obama was running
and he and uh trump was saying about he
wasn't born here and all that said to
the truth or stuff yep
um
i remember he said well if he becomes
president it's the biggest con in
american history
can you projection huh projection so
anyway i'm done rambling take care love
your show bye all right well thank you
very much i appreciate that a beautiful
phone call greg says david sir
congratulations on the massive dumps of
memberships in both streams today
yeah we're actually let me see here
christopher hahn justin gagnon and
michael jor
have just signed up at joinpackman.com
that puts us at 319 and then thanks to
another gift from kyoko
that puts us at 3 20
and then thanks to leslie hieronymus
we are now at 321
so we have an incredibly ambitious goal
of 350.
we're within striking distance we are
very very much within striking distance
here
attendees got get to walk back through
the mud puddles to get to their cars or
look for the missing buses while
stranded in the dark
but donate obama
yeah it's very hard to leave a trump
rally that's actually true
remember this is the same guy who left
his own supporters to freeze in the cold
dangerously he's not above completely
flaking and never showing up that's
actually interesting does anybody in the
audience think trump simply won't show
at all i don't know that that's ever
happened but does anyone think trump
will just not show up
make donald trump again
it seems most of the audience believes
trump is eventually showing up
oh a couple people think it'll be a
no-show
i think i i'm not aware of him bailing
on a rally on the day of in in this way
i'm just not aware of that
thanks to face plant cagers
for the five gifted subscriptions via
twitch putting us at 326. let's see what
they're rambling about for his mindset
was very close to the
america first agenda but it was the
school board issues it was a grassroots
effort from parents
uh and and teachers that the one to push
back on this which pushed him into
office so it's important so to all your
point to uh to your point to unpack
everything it takes small people can
make a big difference in this world oh
essential that's a small reality of like
your political footprint yeah no i think
i think that's absolutely true and
president trump
president trump was essential for glenn
young to win that race even though he
didn't necessarily come out and directly
endorse him he did
that's an interesting revisionist bit of
history they weren't necessarily
terribly excited about selenium because
he might have been a little bit more
establishment and donald trump was very
vocal and said hey patriots you've got
to get out you've got to vote for glenn
younkin and he encouraged his maga
supporters in virginia to go vote for
glenn youngen and ultimately obviously
glenn young won that election yeah and i
was out there last couple rallies there
before election night there uh in
northern virginia and it looked very
much like a trump rally i mean i'm
talking about the bleachers the signage
the flags the crowd the messaging so
yeah it that was a great play uh as far
as glenn youncan is concerned to look at
the fact that the school board situation
was unfolding like it did and then used
that
wow
they are completely disconnected from
reality
hey david so i'm watching the waukesha
wisconsin um
um trump
you know event and when that guy um
came on with the jacket and all you
could see is jews on his t-shirt
when he would stand at a certain angle
um
the the podium said save america and it
just basically looks like jews save
america indeed and uh we did comment on
that it was a bizarre
bizarre bizarre moment
very very strange
hey david this is sherry ellison in
delaware just wanted you to know that
i've been following your live stream
for what we were all hoping was
uh trump getting ready to make a fool
out of himself yet another time
and it's disappointing that the only way
he does that is by being so
unprofessional but he can't even bother
to show up
on anything like on time
anyway
um just
as somebody who used to be a registered
republican and i mean right up until
about six months into that guy's
presidency
he is such a freaking disappointment
i mean he's nothing like
what i grew up believing republicans
were oh he i mean he has nothing to do
with what the old school i'm not saying
it as a way of praising the old
republican party i'm not
but there's just very little connection
but there is a direct line
the reactionary unhinged nature of
trumpist republicans it does stem from
uh the previous versions of republicans
but they are very different both can be
true
both can be true
hey david my name's dustin i've been
listening to your show for a few years
absolutely see things like you do which
makes it pretty easy but yeah
appreciate everything you do been
subscribed for years thank you my
question is
i was talking to my girlfriend recently
and she's more into the social realm and
she was saying how
trump's son had came out on twitter that
he was trans and they found out and
immediately made him pull all these
socials and then what
trump's son came out as trans that i've
never heard that
are you talking about i don't even know
what that's about
uh
has anyone ever heard anything like that
baron or who are you even talking about
man i don't know
hey david i'm candy and i love listening
to you
but i just have to say today i don't
remember the name of the guy
but it was um during your cpac coverage
that you made fun of him for wanting
applause and you did like the best
impression it was beautiful
and somebody should clip that
i think it was the rick scott speech
if anybody has a clip i would i would
definitely check that out
what's up david this is michael from
montreal quebec canada i was simply
wondering if you uh
intended to do some uh fan meetings uh
while you're on uh eating some of the
teams so uh let us know bye-bye
you know i would consider doing a fan
meet-up in uh montreal i would i would
consider that i'm gonna be in montreal
most of the second half of august of
2022 that's this current month for
people who are unaware of when what
month it is um
i would consider doing a fan meeting
but one would be like how many people
would actually go because i don't want
to
i want it to be worth doing if i'm gonna
do it
we would need to figure out logistics
um
and
i'm not against it i'm gonna have a
bunch of free time i'm just gonna be for
most of the time i'm in montreal i'm
just gonna be hanging i actually have
some family that's moving up there
and i'm going to help with the move
quite frankly
and just hang a little bit
so i would be up for doing that in
theory you know there's actually another
thing i don't even know that i want to
broach this but there's a canadian
politician who's somewhat well known
who i'm in touch with and who i'm
planning to meet up with while i'm there
it might be interesting to do a meet and
greet with them as well but i mean again
it's like all of these layers of
complexity it's just one after another
afternoon it starts to get complicated
but
i'm up for doing a meet-up but it's sort
of beyond me to plan it right now
i guess that's where i am
that's where i am
hi bad david this is dustin again
obviously trump has a few sons but i was
speaking about baron
yeah i have not heard that baron is
transgender i have never ever ever heard
that hey david i definitely think trump
is going to cancel but it will be
interesting to see the endurance i think
it's already clear he's not because it
looks like secret service is already
they just came out so i don't think
trump's going to cancel i think the only
question remaining is we're at 326
members right now can we get to 350
before trump speaks elizabeth durin
just signed up on my website and put us
at 3 27
sherry bailey just signed up on my
website and now pushes us to 3 28. the
only question in my mind
in my mind
is do we get to 350 before trump speaks
and mr g says 300 400 500 when is it
enough well we're looking for 350. any
thoughts on where trumpist energy might
have been directed if trump had never
won the presidency
i think they just go back to what they
were doing before i don't know what it
is
but it's not being involved in politics
um
let's see what else we have here
um
couple other voicemails hey david my
wife melissa and i are watching your
stream right now
and i just want to say thank you for the
years of unhinged donald trump content
thank you oh well thank you hold on i'm
coming whoa
trump's getting edgy there geez
uh welcome and thank you to you and your
wife melissa for watching
hey dave i watch your show a lot um i
was just wondering that guy that was on
um with uh
the front of his shirt said jews on it
you know because of his blazer
um he said he worked his way from the
bottom of the nuclear power industry to
the top
that was kind of weird he looked like he
was about 25 years old i mean no no that
guy's in his that guy's in his 40s i
think let me see
j.r majewski he's 42 yeah so i mean i
don't know it is a weird it was a weird
thing for him to say how is that even
possible
how do people not pick up on the blatant
lies
i think he did work
in uh nuclear power i don't think that
was a lie
hi david this is nick from cincinnati i
remember back when uh it was your
birthday someone mentioned on the show
that you got a shipment of ice cream
from graters and i was just wondering
what your favorite flavor of grater's
ice cream is that's a fair question it's
the it's the chair black cherry
chocolate chip
this is the this is my favorite grater's
ice cream right here
black cherry chocolate chip it's an
absolutely perfect ice cream
um and i know people will come to me and
they'll say sir with with tears in their
eyes they talk to me about ben and
jerry's cherry garcia i hate to say it
this is not a political statement we've
had ben cohen on the show from ben and
jerry's and it's all it's all great okay
cherry garcia
can't hold a candle to black cherry
chocolate chip from graeter's
i've said it before and i i will say it
again
it just is what it is
i want to say thank you to jordan burns
patrick cappell
carl rosa
for signing up at joinpackman.com
putting us at 3 31. folks we may make it
to 350 before trump speaks
jason sickmeyer and john gray as well as
laura lewis have just gifted three
subscriptions that puts us at 3 34.
uh let's see what else we've got robert
charles has just signed up and that puts
us at 3 35
and there it is s prez has just dumped
in 20 more
twitch memberships
putting us at 355's
elements of bathrooms there we go 355s
let's go
for 400
can it be done is it even possible
the kids say it's not it does look like
trump will be arriving shortly although
the platforms you can watch some of the
earlier stuff we did walking around the
crowd talking to the people asking them
why they're there and we found that a
lot of people uh here today are from
different parts of the country we've got
new york city we got los angeles we got
atlanta imagine traveling to wisconsin
from la
to stand around all day with these fetid
sani cans
unbelievable adam steen is on his way
over
so we're gonna get to talk to him i'm
really excited folks s prez has just
dumped in
50 more twitch memberships putting us at
405. folks let's go for 450 is it even
criminal
i believe it is my accountant is at the
door
thanks to andrew avr drums who pushes us
with a gifted membership to 406
they tell me they've never seen these
numbers before
uh
and that may well be true
that may well be true from what i'm
understanding look at this crowd the
speaker of the assembly he's uh the
assemblyman the representative from the
63rd
district in wisconsin
has been in wisconsin politics for
decades and it's time for him to go the
whole movement of toss voss
is an attempt to get him removed from
office and adam steen was the
gentleman who was willing to put himself
out there and say i'll run against him
yeah took real courage to do that thanks
to skittle stew for the five gifted
subscriptions although today s prez is
really the star
skittle stew is still the all-time
leader but esprez coming in out of
nowhere with 100
more gifted subscriptions putting us at
511 for the day
i believe espres has set skittle stew in
their sights
i wish i could even see the totals
because i'm curious
i can't even find this
i want to see who's actually leading
right now thanks to ma boss as well
for the additional gifted subscription
i actually don't know who the leader is
kenneth mosley
also appreciate the subscription on the
website kenneth thank you very very much
folks i believe we have set a record i
think maybe like on an election day we
were in the 600s but i don't think i've
ever seen anything like this
ever ever ever
and um where is the who is the leader
now i don't remember
um
gifting happening now i don't even know
what's happening i i think i've lost
control of the stream
this is a real amateur thing you don't
want to lose control of your own stream
silent bang has just gotten a twitch
prime subscription super chats continue
coming in graveborne has just gifted 50
more subscriptions via youtube literally
as donald trump makes a two-hour late
entrance putting us at 564. folks we are
setting the goal at 600
we are setting the goal at 600 and we
will see what happens
uh people are contacting me saying they
personally know skittle stew and that
she is one of the best people in the
world this is incredible skittle stew
with endorsements
literally at the stroke of trump
that sounds weird at the stroke of trump
we get to 564 folks let's take it all in
and see where we can get trump literally
two hours later
[Applause]
[Music]
what a mess what an absolute man he gets
off the helicopter what a difference in
in physiology of the two and not to
mention the mental status as well
folks take a listen he's approaching the
the stage he's going to soak it in a
little bit he's going to take the crowd
they're happy to see him they're
thrilled to see him they've been waiting
they're excited
now let me tell you you're watching
newsmax right here right now does that
look like a man who came to wisconsin
just to support
some other candidates for saying
no i mean he's two hours late certainly
he doesn't care about them that's for
damn sure
um
additional single memberships keep
dumping in and we may indeed get to 600
donald trump looking particularly
disheveled thanks to patrick cappell and
andrew avr drums for the two gifted
memberships on my website donald trump
is in wisconsin this is going to be
completely and totally nuts completely
and totally nuts
[Music]
will he explain why he's late let me
know in the chat
and i want to say a very big hello to a
place called wisconsin has anyone ever
heard of it i think so
it's great to be back in this
magnificent state with thousands of
proud hard-working american patriots
that's you
three months from now the people of
wisconsin are going to fire your radical
democrat governor tony evers
he's a real beauty
and you're going to send tim michaels an
incredible success story tim michaels to
the governor's mansion and you're going
to re-elect the amazing ron johnson so
respectfully let's hope not great people
and you got others you know that we're
going to elect an incredible slate of
america first republicans up and down
the ballot and we are going that was the
first glitch i hope people heard him
what was she doing in taiwan
oh she was chyna's dream she gave them
an excuse
they've been looking for the it's
actually quite the opposite i think it
made sense for nancy pelosi to go to
taiwan
it's actually defiant to china to go to
taiwan but i don't think this crowd
would understand that the first movement
exceptional
you probably saw that the trump endorsed
candidates blake masters easily won
nomination for the u.s senate in arizona
carrie lake won the nomination for
arizona governor tudor dixon won the
nomination for michigan governor
john gibbs great guy defeated rhino
congressman peter meyer
peter meyer he spells it i've never seen
trump this slurry so right off the bat
he's not so different though because he
lost
this week where
45 wins
and no losses is that good
and
in texas
a few weeks ago 33-0 and plenty of those
candidates were not expected to win now
we're going up and down looking at these
victories with a massive win on tuesday
right here
in a place called wisconsin there's
somebody right over there tim you better
win you're going to win
tim michaels he's going to win
he's gonna win i'm also pleased to
announce that just today we chose
milwaukee for the 2024 republican
national convention
that'll be something huh
just look at a big screen how do i look
from behind
looks like his hair is trying to
[Applause]
not
escape
thank you right now this is not a cult
no if you think this might be a cult
it's definitely not a cult no thank you
[Applause]
you could take the five worst presidents
in american history and put them
together and they would not have done
the damage joe biden has done to our
country in less than two short that jobs
report today was just so bad huh
administration's amazing success and we
had amazing success
and joe biden's breathtaking failure
could not be more stark
let's take a look at some of the facts
less than two years ago when i was in
office gasoline gasoline for cars
1.87 cents a gallon so it was actually
227. and now it's five six seven and
even eight dollars
isn't it down dramatically let's find
the price five cents in a place called
california eight dollars and 25 cents
and you're going to be following along
we gave you the largest tax cuts and
regulation cuts in american history even
larger than the reagan tax cuts that
once held the record we broke it by a
lot the radical democrats now intend to
impose the biggest tax hike in american
history the exact opposite of what
i did
and they are working feverishly to pile
on more regulations at levels never seen
before you're gonna have regulations
like nobody's ever seen before
mitch mcconnell got taken for a ride by
joe manchin and the group and the great
people of west virginia where i won by
like 45 points or something have been
seriously hurt
by these political antics joe manchin
has totally sold out west virginia what
he's done to that state is disgraceful
and i told the old broken crow mitch
mcconnell that this was going to happen
i said it's going to happen to you mitch
it's going to happen to you under the
trump administration we had the greatest
economy in the history of the world with
no inflation by the back in five biden
created the worst inflation in 49 years
minimum 9.1 but it's much higher than
that and it's going higher
it's costing families nearly 6 000
a year
we created seven million new jobs the
lowest unemployed we had the best
numbers of any administration ever in
our history for african americans
hispanic americans asian americans
women men
young people without
college diplomas without high school
diplomas with phds from mit harvard the
wharton school of finance we had
everybody covered everybody covered
we had a record
164 million people working that's far
far higher than it is today you know
that we achieved the largest poverty
reduction in over 50 years we lifted
seven million people off food stamps
never happened before and we lifted 10
million people off of welfare never
happened before
and then we got hit by china
with the china virus and after the
pandemic we handed the radical democrats
the fastest
growing economic recovery ever recorded
in history the fastest ever and they
lived off that for a year and a year and
a half
now they've turned that into two
straight quarters of negative economic
growth
also known as a thing called a recession
let's hope that recession doesn't morph
into depression
you know depression is slightly worse
like by a factor of about a hundred
and labor force participation is the
worst
in many many decades i rebuilt our
military including our
nuclear capability and hope to god we
never have to use it
and the creation of space force first
time that's happened since
air force 79 years ago
they surrendered our strength and our
great great soldiers what they did in
afghanistan into the greatest
humiliation our country has ever seen i
believe it was the most
humiliating period of time there's never
been a humiliation like that for our
country
not the fact that we were leaving but
the way we were
leaving it was a surrender and there was
no reason to surrender
they hadn't killed an american soldier
in
18 months
abdul
don't do it abdul
and he didn't do it 18 months we went
and then we took the military out first
how stupid was that
we created the safest border in u.s
history we ended catch and release we
deported record numbers of illegal alien
gang members we got them out of our
country and we built hundreds of miles
of border wall brand new beautiful
border wall in fact
we completely finished our original
border wall plan despite two and a half
years of democrat inspired lawsuit they
sued us all the time two and a half
years it took we won all the lawsuits
and then we completed the wall and we
added much more wall than originally
planned and almost got that finished
also would have been three weeks three
weeks it could have
the job could have been done but they
decided we don't want a wall we want
open borders let everybody come in no
matter who they are does it matter
our border
just two years ago was the best and
safest in u.s recorded history
and they have turned it into the worst
in history by far maybe for any country
and that includes third world countries
there's never been a country that's
allowed people to pour into their
country and it could be the worst
managed the worst countries third world
countries nobody's ever had a border
like we have there's never been anything
like this it's a catastrophe and instead
of being proudly energy independent
which we were less than two years ago
even energy dominant the united states
is now a beggar for energy we're begging
biden and the radical left have turned
calm into chaos
competence into incompetence stability
into anarchy
prosperity into poverty and security
into catastrophe
i wonder if biden could have said that
what i just said you think
there would have been an explosion
then they would have said oh he did so
well tonight he decided the election was
rigged and stolen and now our country is
being
systematically destroyed
last month the wisconsin supreme court i
give such credit to them rule that the
widespread use of ballot drop boxes
across the state is totally illegal
so you know what that means that means
they were obviously illegal in the 2020
election
hundreds and hundreds of thousands of
votes and we were right
there we won this thing by a lot we won
this state by a lot just as i've said
all along the use of these unmanned
unsecured drop boxes was never
authorized by the state legislature by
law it has to be was never they never
got approval
but
no more dropbox
drop boxes all right so in all
seriousness even i didn't expect trump
to be two hours late
so i can stay with you guys until the
bottom of the next hour if you want me
to just leave the speech running i've
got to go and deal with you know my
newborn daughter um
i i'll gladly just leave the speech
running if people want we no longer have
ballots for republicans we only have
them now think of this
how did they get away with this one but
carrie lake
and blake people saying it'll be over in
40 minutes
hell no it won't be over in 40 minutes
how would you like to have that right at
the beginning i'm sorry we have no
longer we just don't have i'm sorry we
have no longer any republican ballots
democrats come right ahead
and then they say the elections are
honest we are also like a third world
country this never happened elections
as the wisconsin supreme court said in
its decision
if the right to vote is to have
any meaning at all elections must be
conducted according to law
really great
the drop box scam in wisconsin and other
states many other states was in addition
to the outrageous stealing of votes from
the elderly at wisconsin's nursing homes
you know that hundreds of thousands of
votes you know for years it was a very
very few people voted from a nursing
home
but this year you had almost 100 this is
also a lie it's totally untrue so much
and you know how they found out about it
the sons and daughters of parents were
irate
my father was comatose my father
was very ill my father didn't vote
oh yes he did no my father didn't this
literally did not happen horrible thing
that took place
but fortunately
a gentleman justice
michael gableman put it very strongly in
his report
one of the most highly respected
people in your state
justice gableman said rampant fraud and
abuse occurred statewide
and he went on to
excoriate the election and what happened
where is michael where is he michael
stand up please he excoriated it
michael gable
took great courage
which side of the civil war would trump
have been on didn't have the courage to
say what they knew was true
i ran twice i won twice did much better
the second time than i did the first
getting millions more votes in 2020 than
we got in 2016. i was told that if we
got the same number there's no way we
could lose we got millions and millions
more votes and likewise getting more
votes than any sitting president in the
history of our country by far
and now
we may just have to do it again right we
may have to do it again and bring our
country back
wow what excitement at that prospect
i love how trump keeps the rallies fresh
and covers new ground at each of them
thank you but first we have to win a
historic victory for the republican
party there's some great people in this
party
it's going to happen in november when we
retake congress among our highest
priorities must be to end the nightmare
joe biden has created on our southern
border
millions and millions and millions of
people pouring in
unchecked nobody knows where they're
from
last week we had
129 countries represented
of people that came into our country
illegally we know nothing about them
we're going to pay a price for many many
years to come we must know something if
we know the countries they came from
right they're pouring across our border
other countries are emptying out their
prisons and sending the worst criminals
the world has ever known right into the
united states we're like a dumping
ground
they're emptying their jails into our
country they don't want them back they
said let's get them out very expensive
to keep them
so they're just dumping them right into
the united states they're coming in all
different ways including
just weeks ago a savage illegal alien
criminal in pennsylvania already
suspected of two prior stabbings
shot an innocent 76 year old man in the
back of the head while the man was out
for his morning walk
earlier this year a ms-13 gang member
these are the worst of the worst
was sentenced for helping lure a teenage
boy to a playground
beating him in the head
and brutally stabbing him 32 times to
death
two other illegal alien ms-13 gang
members in texas were convicted for
raping and murdering a 15 year old girl
in a
by the way if they were already
convicted given how slowly the justice
system worked it's completely plausible
that the crimes happened while trump was
president i mean i i just don't know
about the individual stories he brings
up but if we're already at a conviction
meaning the trial has ended and the
pre-trial has
it's completely plausible that that
happened while trump was still in office
it's of ice and the border patrol and
the police generally law enforcement's
been incredible in this country they got
to be allowed to do their job
the radical democrats have turned our
country into one giant sanctuary for
dangerous criminal aliens
in the republican party we believe our
country should be a sanctuary for law
abiding citizens who love america
and if we're going to make america great
again our first task is to make america
safe again no crime
right here in milwaukee last year
murders reached an all-time high and in
2022 homicides are up
listen to this 38
from one year ago worse it's ever been
the worst it's ever been and you could
say that about many almost all almost
every single democrat run
city in our country under a republican
congress we should pass emergency
funding to hire thousands more police
officers and we will do that trump
literally can't get anything right there
have been 38 more homicides in milwaukee
this year not 38
more but it's like does it even really
matter
back their respect they know what to do
we have to allow them to do it
right
kim knows
and instead of targeting republicans
conservatives christians and patriotic
parents the biden administration should
try going in and dismantling
the street gangs and vicious criminal
cartels that are dominating these
democrat
run cities
and instead of taking guns away from law
abiding americans we should try taking
them away from the violent felons and
career criminals for a change enforcing
existing statutes their existence
to get them in jail
right
stop and frisk let's do it again
if you look at countries throughout the
world the only ones that don't have a
drug problem and they have none
whatsoever
are those that institute the depth
penalty for drug dealers sounds tough
but i'm so tired of setting up blue
ribbon committees composed of nice
people wonderful people and they're not
going to be successful in dealing with
these savages
you know when i was in china
i said to president xi i got along with
him very well but once covet came we did
a great deal actually with them trade
deal helped our farmers our
manufacturers great deal i said to
president xi maybe naively
do you have a drug problem in china no
he looked at me like what a stupid
question
no no we don't the drug problem they
have is they send drugs to us that's our
problem
but they stop doing it very much so but
i said uh president
do you have a drug problem no no no no
we don't you don't i said wow that's
amazing uh what do you attribute that to
quick trial
i said what's a quick trial that means a
quick trial means exactly what it says
quick trial
and they have the death penalty for drug
dealers this is trump's new thing
talking about killing drug dealers the
united states are someplace else where
nothing happens to us if we're going to
stop this scourge
and this is a big factor for the crime
in our country drugs
it's time to get brutally tough on the
dealers traffickers and narco terrorist
cartels who are stealing millions and
millions of lives killing people in our
country if you want to make our country
safe for violent i'll tell you what
if you want to make it safe for violent
criminals just vote for the radical
democrats because they're never going to
change if you want to make them safe for
your family your children and for law
abiding americans you must vote for
republicans you have to do it
you know the drug dealers
each drug dealer here we go kills we're
not even talking about destroying and
destruction of families and destroying
lives kills
approximately 500 people each
think about how idiotic that you know in
high school there was this guy named
chris who would sell pot
he was responsible for 500 murders
thousands of people are killed
i believe we lost last year 250 000
people
died from illegal drugs coming over our
border
and two years ago we had that down to
the lowest number in many many years we
had the wall it's like this is the type
of thing that doesn't even pass the
sniff test even remotely
they had no choice otherwise we would
have put tariffs all over the place they
said we would love to give you the
soldiers we would love to
free of charge sir
they were great sir they were great i
really like the president he's a
socialist but that's okay that doesn't
make him a bad person but we have some
real bad ones in this country
but it was uh
amazing the job we did
our country doesn't win anymore we don't
win with our military with education
with trade we're gonna win with anything
we just don't win we're going to start
winning again
just like we were
two years ago
globalished
right here in wisconsin we have some
critically important elections coming up
starting with the primaries this tuesday
august 9th
got to get out you got to vote
you have the opportunity to vote for
true conservative warriors
starting with the next governor of
wisconsin tim michaels
trump is the least enthused when he has
to talk about the other candidates
that he's ostensibly here to support oh
you know he's a businessman and he'll
own something little friend of mine just
asked me when i mentioned i was
streaming the rally they were like
what's trump rallying for i was like i
don't even know it doesn't make any
sense he builds massive tunnels and
infrastructures and
bidding like on the lincoln tunnel in
new york and
he boards through earth he boars through
mountains he's uh
now you're born right now one of the
biggest employers in the state and this
is where he's based he's all over the
world building these big tunnels that go
through
incredible granite mountains i say out
of hell i was with him i spent more time
talking about that than i did frankly
politics i said you got to tell me about
the machines that do it they cost 35 to
40 million each
but they're incredible he said they go
through it like butter sir
and i find it very i love construction
i'm sorry
i love construction sure sure he's big
he's big time is the point this is big
stout
the biggest in the world at what he does
tim is a tremendously
successful builder and runs the largest
construction company in your state he
employs more than 8 000 people here
he's a former army ranger most
importantly a proud america first
patriot who is with us right from the
beginning he's been with me for a long
time
introduced by a friend of mine
diane hendricks you know who diana's
you know i heard about this woman diane
this is
six seven years ago and i heard she was
a trump fan i said who the hell is she
she owned some stores i said oh big deal
she had the store
thousands of them
i said who is she how many stores trump
wouldn't care about an actual single
store owner i mean he needs a franchise
to be interested billions
well
naturally because of that i became
extremely friendly with her
and she also happens to be beautiful by
the way
now i don't say that anymore you know in
the old days that say beautiful today i
don't say that i don't even notice that
but she is she's a great
woman but she introduced me to tim she
said you would you do us a favor we need
to be so badly in the state the state is
getting hit from so many ways we have
this incompetent governor named evers
you can't call them evers i guess evers
evers
and
we have somebody that's incredible
and you know it takes a lot of courage
to do what he's doing took courage to do
what i'm doing i can tell you damn enjoy
you no one's more courageous than me
but it takes a lot of courage but he's
the real
deal you know under my administration
tim served on my infrastructure task
force i can't think of a better guy than
that he's the biggest in the world he
helped us build
the keystone xl pipeline before biden
shut it down can you imagine that
and even
gave the experts
some real help on the border wall
showing them how to do it how to get it
done because we built hundreds and
hundreds of miles and he was so helpful
in explaining
what to do and the best way to do it as
your governor tim will crack down on
violent crime and he won't play games he
will fight to lower soaring energy costs
create jobs and guarantee free and fair
election tim has always the elections
will be free and fair
tim will always defend your second
amendment i'll be honest i didn't notice
but i see people chatting there is
something very strange about trump's
hairline tonight knock down state
you and
the governor of michigan how about her
the only one she didn't lock down was
her husband
it's true
he went boating he would be boating in
the middle of the lake nobody else was
allowed but he was boating
oh he paid a big price can you imagine
that night
when he came in when he's front page on
every paper
and he says i'm sorry darling don't you
ever do that again very patriotic
killing me
tim's opponent in the primary is
rebecca clayfish
a career politician and a
political insider i've known her for a
long time she's the hand-picked
candidate of the failed establishment
the rhinos and
the washington swamp and she's running a
campaign of falsehoods and lies
clayfish complains about lobbyists but
her husband is one of the biggest
lobbyists in
a place called madison you know madison
as lieutenant governor she went to china
begging for business from chinese
communist party
and the disastrous wisconsin election
commission this commission is a disaster
was created on her watch
most of all
rebecca tleyfish
does not have what it takes to beat tony
evers tony evers is
close to incompetent
but he's going to win if he runs against
rebecca right she already lost to him in
2018 tim michaels will win the primary
he'll win it easily
and in november i know this is going
important but because someone mentioned
this
there is my favorite trump in person
impersonator right now is this guy i
follow on tick tock check this out this
guy i can tell you is the monkey parks
was started by joe biden and kamala so
biden goes to a zoo right he goes to a
zoo he gets a couple of monkeys and he
stabs people with their teeth and they
bite people and that's how it started
it's infecting a lot of men a lot of
excuse me i'll excuse me [ __ ] your mouth
you're nasty men are getting it mike
pence can tell you why more men are
getting it right folks but the monkey
box was started in the zoo but i can
anyway i think this guy's really good
obviously he doesn't have the look
but uh the voice is absolutely perfect
rains if it doesn't rain if you have
drought
everything's climate change you can't
miss they finally got it right
but i'd like to ask tim to come on up
please just for a second tim
is this tim apple
no
thank you sir
sir
all right wisconsin
the greatest thing that we can do is
vote on tuesday and that is the path to
getting rid of tony evers and getting
proper he'd better praise trump or
trump's gonna get bored
we're gonna do it together we are very
powerful this is a great american
meeting tonight since the founding of
our country people coming together
because they're concerned about the
direction of the country because they
want to vet candidates they want to hear
what candidates stand for and i'm
telling you we are going to have
election integrity here in wisconsin
i told you earlier
barbara's did trump just say to him
under his breath keep going i will back
the blue i will get rid of the catch and
release da's i'll fire them and we are
going to have law and order again in the
state of wisconsin
if you care about law and order and the
failing education that's happening here
tony evers
i told you hours ago tony idris has been
an educrat his entire career if there's
one thing in wisconsin that should be
going well it's education he's been a
leader in education for 13 years and
education continues to decline get worse
and worse and worse if he can't do
anything good for education he can't do
anything well at all and that's why
we're gonna fire him and get proper
leadership in the governor's office
i'm honored to be endorsed
by president trump and boy president
john i wish he was president today oh my
god
these people are nuts
it's unbelievable
i love you i love you
you know mike did me 60 minutes
joe biden has made such a mess of things
from the bats
botched afghanistan withdrawal to biden
inflation today tony evers weak trump's
completely bored
when kenosha started burning he didn't
show up for days i am the kind of leader
i would have been there on the first
night in the first hours working with
law enforcement working with the
national guard and those trump's like
who what's he talking about again oh
they weren't going to get away with it
businesses in wisconsin will never burn
again
so i thank you so much i thank you so
much for coming out tonight
but hey what else is going on what else
would you rather be doing than be here
with the 45th president of the united
states donald j trump
a lot of things kind of sound better
virtue
cycling
[Music]
wow that was a good job
that was very good
now he's the real deal you're getting
the real deal you're getting somebody
that's at the top top of the line and
you need it to bring your state back
also here tonight is the next state
representative from wisconsin's 63rd
district
[Applause]
and he's very very important we just did
it in arizona we had a
uh
a house member let's call him he's
called uh he was the boss
and we knocked him out i think he got
like 35
powers we knocked them out we knocked
them out big and you have a similar
problem right here
it was the speaker of the house in
arizona you happen to have the speaker
of the house over here isn't that
interesting
and we had a very good candidate in
arizona and we have an incredible
candidate right here he's worked on this
for a long time
he's just hated to see what was
happening this is not the first time
he's been after this for a long time
because he couldn't stand to look at
what was happening to your state
adam steen is running to defeat your
rhino speaker of the house robin voss
despite undeniable evidence of rigging
and fraud
speaker voss has taken no steps to hold
the wisconsin election commission
accountable clean up the voter rolls or
right any of the other terrible wrongs
that were identified by justice gableman
he identified it at all
in fact dwarf said
we won't let it happen again well what
about 2020. they won't let it happen
again in other words it was okay to
cheat in 2020 but we won't let it happen
again
he will let it happen again but you know
that
he even strongly supports unsecured drop
boxes they're totally unsecured he also
wants to have you pay the gas tax to
drop by very expensive toll roads all
over your state where you can pay tolls
every time you go someplace
it would be devastating for low and
middle-income families and that's why we
need to fire robin voss and replace him
with adam steen how to make sure
oh my
very god race adam is also endorsed by
representative janelle branch and who is
a winner
janelle stood up janelle
she's so incredible what a
great brave woman she is because boss
has blocked all of
her efforts to secure the state's
elections he just blocks them
a lot of people think he's a democrat
actually
adam is a
true patriot on the other hand devoted
to making america great again
so we're joined as well
adam i want to just thank you where is
adam where's adam dan what a job thank
you adam
look at his family i don't believe
that's like from
that's like from a picture
if i ever need you or anything to
promote a hotel i want to use that
family they're perfect put them right on
their look at this family
wow so adam good luck good luck we're
with you all the way i hope you can
knock him out he's been there a long
time he's been there a long time and not
done anything
thank you very much enjoy it
we're also joined
by the next congressman from wisconsin's
third congressional district
derrick van orden where is derek great
job don
you are doing fantastically i'm hearing
about it and he's another one doesn't
stop he is somebody that will not stop i
hear you're doing fantastically well so
good luck close it out close it out we
need you in washington thank you derek
great job thank you and your family
really an electric evening you can tell
again the primer is this tuesday august
9th so get out and vote for derek and
tim michaels and
adam steen i also need to
ask you to vote for a very good friend
of mine and a special man
he's one of the most respected people in
the senate
he has done an incredible job and he'll
take unpopular positions if they're
right his name is senator ron johnson oh
god no get out and vote for ron johnson
horrible person
he's smart and he loves your state and
he loves our country
in addition we're delighted to be joined
this evening by some of my friends
reince priebus where's reigns oh no
took me years and years to learn how to
pronounce his name
and he was very instrumental along with
diane on bringing the convention to
milwaukee so you know good job a lot of
people wanted that convention it's going
to bring in 250 million dollars diane
right so that's a lot 250 million is not
bad
and reince you know won uh more races
actually than any rnc chairman in
history he's a very good guy and good
loves he loves your state can't keep him
away
as well as candidate for congress
in ohio's ninth congressional district a
man named j.r majewski do you know who
that is whoa
you know quick story i was in ohio and
i'm
giving a little speech in front of about
uh 40
smaller crowd
one of our smaller crowds and
i was told that there's somebody named
jr majestic there's like three thousand
people at this speech actually not a
farmer he's a physicist i'd say that's a
big difference right but what the hell
nobody cared
but he was sort of running but not
really running but he was trying to make
a point because he's got some great
points to make and i introduced him to
this massive crowd j.r majewski
and the place went crazy
and he wasn't supposed to be playing in
the race much he was just doing to make
a point but there were four other people
that were serious politicians in the
race by the way i interviewed majewski
there's no evidence that he's a
physicist he just got a bachelor's
degree in science of
no he got a bachelor of science in
business
and then a master's in
management i don't see any evidence that
he's a physicist that's crazy into ohio
once i said look at this
in uh physicists in a way can you
imagine the name trump the letters were
about 60 feet high
i was 30 000 feet up and i said look
there's trump who did that it was jay
armageus
right it's like saying i'm a physicist
because i have an mba why everybody
thought he was a farmer that makes sense
i guess that's what happened right but
we appreciate it j.r and go win your
race you're going to win you're going to
win people love this guy he's great
another man who's great and i've known
him for a long time he's tough as hell
but he's got a big beautiful heart
sheriff david clarke oof
horrible though
horrible
his incredible wife
what a couple what a couple
what a couple and what a sheriff thank
you very much i haven't seen him in a
couple years you look even better than
you did three years ago
what are you doing explain to me what
you're doing please
thanks a lot great sheriff great job
thank you
and
two people that i've slightly mentioned
but i have to have them
stand up
because diane hendricks is a special
woman one of the greatest business
people in our country and yet she's a
very modest person but she's incredible
and i'll tell you what when she gets on
your case she doesn't stop
that phone can ring 30 times i'll call
her right back
she wants it now sir
she is tough and she's smart and she
loves your state
and she was really responsible along
with reince and a few others for getting
the big convention here instead of to a
lot of other places that wanted it so if
you don't mind diane please stand up
crowd doesn't even know which direction
to look at this point
and again
just as michael gableman for the job
that you've done and the
incredible strength that you've said
and you know michael is endorsing
steen
how's that working right
michael is endorsing adam
and that's great it was you know put
there by
ross to do it in a commission
and he went back and he said look at all
this fraud and voss wanted nothing to do
with it it's just a terrible thing so i
want to thank you michael for being here
but i want to thank you much more
importantly for the job
that you've done that's an incredible
report you put out there you go it's a
very sad report actually very sad
hundreds of thousands of votes and the
fraud and abuse but uh we appreciate it
everybody here appreciate all right guys
we're gonna keep the stream going i've
gotta go do baby duty if uh if trump's
still going when i'm done i'll be back
otherwise it'll just be the stream
and then i will also be back tomorrow
for the final day of cpac enjoy and i
will hopefully see y'all later if not
tomorrow after what a disaster the worst
trade deal ever made and replaced it
with the usmca the best trade deal ever
made for our country a massive win for
wisconsin dairy farmers and all of those
dairy farmers they like trump a lot all
over the country but it's a great and i
will tell you it's mexico and canada you
know that and
they want to renegotiate the deal it's
not a good feeling they want to
renegotiate i hope they don't do it but
unfortunately this administration is
already starting to try and renegotiate
the deal to make it better for them
they had us for many years in this nafta
deal it was horrible nobody wanted to
renegotiate it then but now they want to
renegotiate don't do it to defend
wisconsin workers i withdrew from the
terrible trans-pacific partnership would
have ruined your manufacturing
businesses
and i imposed strict tariffs on foreign
aluminum and steel and it saved our
steel industry and it saved our aluminum
industry and now i hear biden wants to
take the tariffs off of china i took in
hundreds of billions of dollars from
china we never got 10 cents not one
president took in 10 cents from china i
took in hundreds of billions of dollars
and now they want to stop
they want to not charge china
when the left-wing mobs came out to sac
the city of kenosha
two years ago this month you remember i
was here i sent the national guard and
we saved the city from total destruction
they would have destroyed this city
that's why i have a very
strong feeling for kenosha it was a
great success and the guard did a
fantastic job
and if i had to wait for the governor
forget it it would have been a long wait
and as part of my administration's
colossal rebuilding of the us military
we delivered major contracts for
wisconsin workers to build brand new
warships helping save the historic
shipyard marinette marine you know that
right
and they're beautiful they're beautiful
they look like yachts with lots of guns
on them actually
now they're beautiful marinette they're
doing a fantastic job but i gave them
the contract it was like six billion
dollars uh other people wanted i said
nope that's going to wisconsin i took a
little heat but it's worked out good
because i hear they're doing a great job
right are they doing a good job tim
we fought for wisconsin and we won for
wisconsin and with a big victory for
republicans this november we will fight
and win for wisconsin once again and win
like never before
one of the first things we'll do
is to stand up for
parents rights can you believe i have to
even say that because the democrats are
can you believe how stupid does that say
we're going to stand up for parents
rights
they're standing against parents who
would think that we this would be a part
of a platform we are going to stand up
for the parents
it's crazy what's happening in this
world and to our country is just crazy
it's time to finally and completely
smash the radical f's corrupt
educational
cartel
our children are captives to unhinged
marxist educators where do they come
from
who are pushing inappropriate sexual
racial and political material on our
children from the youngest possible age
and the parents are sitting home
thinking your children are being
beautifully educated and they're
listening to these marxists and these
crazy people at long last every parent
in america must be empowered to opt out
of this indoctrination and send their
child to the public private charter
religious or home school of their choice
have to be able to do it
in addition we will get
critical race theory
a disaster out of our schools out of our
military i already took it out of our
military our schools they put it back
immediately first day in office and out
of every part of our federal state and
local governments i had it gone
and when the election results came in
the first thing they did was put it back
in disgraceful
we did win by a lot
we will also keep men
out of women's sports if that's okay
can you believe it
no no can you believe it
men
men are
you know the sewers of the swimmer
should i tell it you probably heard it
should i or not
so we have this young
female swimmer great
really great she's a champion
and she wants to break
the united states record
in some kind of an event
and she needed about one-eighth of a
second
and she was standing on the line and
she's ready to go and i tell the story
it's a crazy story you know i'm not
supposed to be saying because it's
politically incorrect to talk about it
it's politically incorrect they don't
want to talk they don't want to mention
i don't understand why it's politically
incorrect but uh i think that's why i
got elected in the first place
right
but this beautiful athlete wants to
bring one-eighth of a second if she can
do that she's going to be so proud
and you know she looks down to the left
and she sees these beautiful young women
that she's been competing with for many
years for 10 years she knows them all
they sort of grow up you know it's that
perfect triangle at the top
and she sees them and she looks down to
the right and she sees them and she's so
happy to see them and then she looks to
her right over here right next to her
just this giant person
and she didn't really know who
it was
and he was just giving the female
athlete of the year by the way did you
know that
no no think of this
is our country going to hell or what
okay
nothing right look
i'm sure a very nice person but he you
know he had a wingspan like this he was
giant
she's looking up she said oh my god he
looks like he could be trouble or
she looks like
and
it was quite scary but she figured she's
the best so she's going to win well she
was badly injured in that race you know
why wind burned he went by her so fast
that she got tremendous wind burn
she's still trying to recover actually
and she didn't break the record but he
did he won by
38 seconds
not one-eighth of it she wanted to win
by one-eighth of a second now this is
really
really doing harm to the woman's
movement this is a ridiculous thing
the best of all though is the weight
lifter you heard about the weight lifter
so
a woman
weight lifter i think it was 218 pounds
i'm not sure i got to be careful because
the fake news will say it wasn't 218 it
was 236 it's terrible whatever the hell
it was she wanted to
break the record by
one-eighth of an ounce on each side so
they put this they have these big
you know big heavy
barbells and they have on the sides all
the weights right
and they put the little tiny bit here
little tiny bit there
and she went over and she was so proud
and she stood over those weights and she
went like this
ah
she was proud of her mother and father
were screaming they were so proud of
there
they said girl
i'm so proud of my girl he said
and she got over the weight since she
lifted him up got him up to here and
then
ah
oh
no not enough ah
she couldn't make it
she didn't make it
just missed just very close actually
but she missed
and then this
person in a male's body that's what you
say you know because they call it a
person in a male's body happened to come
up
and they said have you lifted before he
said that much i don't know too much
about it
and he stood over the weights
he wins
[Applause]
he could have lifted another 200 pounds
over his head
we are hurting women very badly i i said
the other day i would be the greatest
coach in the history of
women's basketball
i would go to le bar i don't like lebron
james at all i think he's a terrible
person terrible [ __ ]
i would go to lebron james despite my
dislike
and i would say lebron have you ever
thought of being a woman
because i'm a coach
and i want you on my team and i want to
get a few other guys perhaps from the
nba to be on my team i would have the
greatest team in history
they would never lose they would win
every game by 70 80 maybe 90 points
it's crazy what they're doing to
women's sports is a disgrace it's a
disgrace and it's very unfair to a thing
called the women's movement because i'm
a big believer in the women's movement
and it's a very unfair thing so whether
it's politically
appropriate or not i'll say it it's a
disgrace what they're doing how stupid
is it
no teacher
should ever be allowed to teach
transgender to our children without
parental consent
what they're doing to your children
essentially behind your back is
crazy
it's hard to believe you know when
you're up here and you're doing this and
you're
looking at different notes and you're
going and i mean who would think that
we'd be talking about this let's say ten
years ago six seven years ago who would
ever believe we're even talking about
this when republicans retake congress
they also need to crack down hard on
big pharma for giving puberty blockers
and other dangerous drugs
to mutilate our youth puberty do you
think we'd be talking about puberty
blockers
seven eight nine years ago
we will save our kids and every federal
bureaucrat who is complicit in this
travesty needs to
immediately be fired
you're fired beats you got to be fired
or
worse
another one of the highest
priorities for the republican congress
will be to stop left-wing censorship and
restore free speech in america we don't
have free speech
we don't have them
and by the way go out now and sign up
for truth social we're getting the word
out it's amazing it's hot and it's much
much much better than
twitter twitter's suffering greatly
lately do you notice that isn't that too
bad the radical left democrat party is
not a 50 party within our country
they're against god guns oil
law enforcement voter id tax cuts
regulation cuts the constitution
they're against our founding fathers
but actually other than that they're
quite nice aren't they
the way they win is to cheat in
elections i really believe that they
cheat in elections they're professionals
if they devoted that genius to
fighting for us against foreign
countries we wouldn't be ripped off by
every country in the world everywhere
the republican party has the chance we
must pass critical election integrity
reforms including universal voter id
citizenship confirmation can you believe
that
we want to prove that you're a citizen
they don't want to allow that
we want to get rid of
fake drop boxes they're a fake
you know if you're a uh
citizen and you want to contribute to
your local congressman or senator
if you as a husband and wife give more
than 5 600 they get they put you in jail
and yet
zuckerbucks gave
500
i guess million 417 they have they have
no idea but think of it
if you give 200 too much they put you in
jail this guy gave they say 417 million
dollars
zuckerberg
no but how sick is it and that money is
being spread all over the place it's a
disgrace and it's focused on democrat
areas you know they they put a little
bit in republican era so they can say we
did both but they didn't it's a disgrace
no private money
pouring into local election offices
should be allowed and ultimately we need
same-day voting with only paper ballots
that's what we need
only paper ballots so france just had an
election you know it's a country big
country 35 million people voted it was
paper ballots and it was a same-day
election one day ten o'clock in the
evening you listened to the results
and my friend macron won
and
a young lady lost and she wasn't
complaining
she lost but they had paper ballots in
that same day voting and you don't use
mail-in ballots except for people that
are very sick or military that's very
far away otherwise they vote here
and we would have great elections once
again and elections that we could count
on
not elections where
carrie lake is waiting for
days and days for the result
we have
an election going on in the state of
washington a congressional election
they think they should have the result
over the next few days think of it it's
a relatively
small number of people
and it's going to be weeks
and they have no idea and you know when
it takes that long what's happening
behind the scenes
we're just three months away from the
most important midterm election in
american history and we need a landslide
so big that the radical left cannot rig
it or steal it
this is the year we're going to take
back the house we're going to take back
the senate and we're going to take back
america
and in 2024 most importantly we are
going to take back our magnificent white
house we're going to take it back
but first we have to secure a massive
victory for tim michaels in this primary
so go get your friends go get your
family
and go
get out to vote that's going to be a
very important election so tim good luck
right go and get them
together we will fight for more jobs for
wisconsin families fair trade for
wisconsin workers and more wisconsin
factories forging more products stamped
with that beautiful phrase
made in the usa
we will shut down biden's border
disaster reinstitute our strong remain
in mexico policy strengthen the patriots
of ice and border patrol
we will again
end catch and release one of the dumbest
programs ever we will end chain
migration we will end the visa lottery
and we will clamp down on illegal
immigration just like we did less than
two years ago
when we set record lows on illegal
immigration
and drugs
we will stop the crime wave in
democrat-run cities we will give our
police the power they need and the
respect they deserve and we will not
take immunity protection away from our
police
we will restore law and order in america
we will hold china accountable for
unleashing the virus upon the world
we will protect innocent life we will
defend our constitution we will defend
our totally under siege
second amendment it's under siege they
want to take your guns away
the bad guys can have guns because
they're not giving them up so the bad
guys will have the guns
and we will proudly uphold the
judeo-christian values and principles of
our nation's family
we will restore patriotic education to
our schools and we will teach our
children to love their country honor our
history and to always respect our great
american flag
and in conclusion
our maga movement the greatest movement
of all times in this country and in many
other countries no matter where you go
it's the greatest
political movement of all time probably
the greatest movement of all time and
you know the fake news is back there a
lot of them they never even question me
on it you know if i say something that's
slightly off diane they say oh that was
they've never questioned i say it's the
greatest political movement of all time
in our country and beyond our country
too but
in our country
and they never question me the fake news
together we are standing up against some
of the most menacing forces
entrenched interests and vicious
opponents our people have ever seen
a friend of mine recently said that i
was the most persecuted person in the
history of our country
when i thought about it i actually felt
that
he may very well be right
we had a russia-russia-russia scam that
was
covered religiously by the
media even though they knew it was fake
news they knew it they knew it all it
all came out it turned out to be a
concocted fairy tale made up by crooked
hillary clinton to democrats and a
sleazeball writer named christopher
steele
and a coordinated effort with of all
places you know who they worked with
russia they worked with russia do you
believe this this could only happen to
me
then i had
impeachment hooks number one impeachment
oaks number two and the mueller
investigation resulting in a verdict
after two years of no collusion they
said trump didn't collude with russia
who has been through anything like this
seriously
certainly no politician and definitely
no president
all of this while i was doing so much as
president including creating the most
secure border in american history
record tax and regulatory cuts
1.87
gasoline no inflation
low interest rates record growth in real
wages greatest economy in history
rebuilding our entire military
the historic abraham accords
bringing peace
to the middle east
jerusalem
the capital of israel
and so much more
now we have the january 6
unselect committee of political hacks
and fox
[Applause]
and these are the very same people who
perpetrated the lies that i was an agent
of russia like
shifty adam schiff
watermelon head and others
who were standing before the same
microphones that they have for the last
five years
and doing the exact same thing with
january 6 as they did with all the
previous assaults on our country and on
my family they assaulted my family
think of it
adam schiff made up along with crooked
hillary and others they made up the
russia hooks and then i watched adam
schiff stand at the microphones so
sanctimonious
and say
donald trump jr
should go to jail for what he did with
russia now think of that he made up a
story a fake story and he's suggesting
that my son a good kid go to jail on a
story that he knows is fake what do you
think about that diane not good right
so where does it stop where does it end
it probably doesn't probably not stop
because
despite outside dangers we have great
outside dangers with china and russia
and if we're not careful we're going to
end up in world war iii i can tell you
that because we're not handling anything
right
our biggest threat remains the sick
sinister and evil people from within our
country the same people that we're
talking about never forget everything
this corrupt establishment is doing to
me is all about
preserving their power and control over
the american people you
they want to damage me in any form so i
can no longer represent the hard-working
citizens of our country
and based on the poll numbers they're
going to have to start doing it because
we're leading everybody republicans and
democrats and
so i guess that's their only option
and the fake news media these people
right back there a lot of them
is totally complicit in what's happening
if i renounce my beliefs
if i agreed to stay silent if i stayed
home or if i stayed in my basement like
joe biden did
the persecution
would stop immediately
that's what they want me to do and it
would all be very nice i'd have a very
nice life
but i can't do that and i will not do
that because i love our country and the
people of our country i love them so
much
and i'm not doing this for me because i
had a very good and luxurious life
before entering the wonderful world of
politics i'm doing this for you and it's
my honor to do it
[Music]
because if i don't do it
i believe our nation is doomed to become
another venezuela or become another
soviet union or become a very
large-scale version of cuba where all is
lost and there is no hope whatsoever
no matter
how big or powerful the corrupt radicals
we are fighting against may be
you must never forget this nation does
not belong to them
this nation belongs to you belongs to
you
this is your home this is your heritage
and our american liberty is your
god-given right
from madison to milwaukee
from janesville to green bay from
kenosha to right here in waukesha
we inherit the legacy of wisconsin
patriots who braved
incredible dangers to carve out life in
a vast
and wild but wonderful frontier
we stand on the shoulders of american
giants who crossed the oceans explored
the continent
settled the great plains won the wild
west
laid down the railroads raised up the
incredible beautiful great skyscrapers
conquered the skies
fought two world wars and one
defeated fascism and communism mastered
space flight
and made america into the single
greatest nation in the history
of the world
[Applause]
but now we are a nation
in decline
we are a nation that is failing
we are a nation
that is hurting so badly
we are a nation that has the highest
inflation
in over 40 years
and where the stock market just finished
the worst first half of the year
since 1872.
think of that
likewise we're a nation that has the
highest energy costs in its history
we are no longer energy independent or
energy dominant as we were just two
short years ago we are a nation that is
begging
venezuela
saudi arabia and many others for oil
please please please help us joe biden
says
yet we have more liquid gold under our
feet
than any other country in the world
we are a nation that is consumed by the
radical left's green new deal
yet everyone knows that the green new
deal will lead to our destruction
we are a nation that surrendered in
afghanistan
leaving behind dead soldiers
american citizens and 85 billion dollars
worth of the finest military equipment
anywhere in the world
we are a nation that allowed russia to
devastate a country ukraine killing
hundreds of thousands of people
and it will only get worse
it would never have happened with me as
your commander-in-chief
and it didn't
it didn't happen never happened
and china
with taiwan
is next just watch what's happening you
see it happening before you how stupid
it was that she went
we are a nation that has weaponized its
law enforcement like never before
against
the opposing political party
they send their law enforcement out to
get them because they can't beat us at
the polls so let's
lock them up we are a nation that no
longer has a free and fair press
fake news is all you get
and they are the
enemy of the people we are a nation
where free speech is no longer allowed
where crime is rampant like never before
where the economy has been collapsing
where more people died of covet in 2021
than in 2020
we are a nation that is allowing iran to
build a massive nuclear weapon
which they are incredibly being allowed
to do right now as we speak and china to
use the trillions and trillions of
dollars
it has taken from past administrations
to build
a military to more than rival our own
and just two years ago
we had iran
china russia and north korea in czech
they weren't going to do a thing against
the united states
they weren't going to hurt us
everyone knows that's true
even the radical left democrats say it
they weren't going to do a thing against
the united states when trump was
president
and perhaps most importantly we are a
nation that is no longer respected or
listened to
around the world
we are a nation that in many ways has
become a joke
and we are a nation that is hostile to
liberty
freedom and faith
we are a nation that allows men to play
sports on women's teams and dominate
those teams
we are a nation whose airports are a
disaster whose flights never leave on
time and whose passengers are stranded
all over our country
we are a nation whose economy is
floundering whose stores are not stocked
whose deliveries are not coming and
whose educational system is ranked at
the bottom of every list
but we are not going to let this
continue
two years ago we had the greatest
country
that we've ever had we were doing better
than we had ever done
and soon we will have greatness again we
will have greatness again
it was hard-working patriots like you
who built this country
and it is hard-working patriots like you
who are going to save our country
we will stand up
to the radical left lunatics and rhinos
and we will fight for america like no
one has ever fought before
there is no mountain we cannot climb
there is no summit we cannot reach
there is no challenge we cannot meet
there is no victory
we cannot have
we will not bend we will not break we
will not yield we will never give in we
will never give up
we will never ever ever back down
as long as we are confident and united
the tyrants we are fighting do not stand
even a little chance
because we are americans and americans
kneel to god and to god alone
[Applause]
[Music]
my fellow citizens this incredible
journey we are on together has only just
begun
and it is time to start talking about
greatness for our country again
we are one movement
one people
one family and one glorious american
nation
so with the help of everyone here today
and the citizens all across our land
we will
make america powerful again
we will make america wealthy again
we will make america strong again
we will make america
proud again
we will make
america safe again
and we
will make america great again thank you
wisconsin thank you very much
thank you very much
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
me
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right folks
there it is what we waited for
[Applause]
[Music]
president trump spends
about an hour in
30 minutes or so
am i right about an hour 30 minutes uh
talking to the the people of wisconsin
talking to the american people and
talking directly to you the newsmax
audience because if you weren't watching
it here you weren't seeing it anywhere
on television you know it struck me as
he did exactly what we thought he may do
prior we were talking about it crime was
his first talking point and that came
out very very very loud applause for
that he probably scored his biggest
round of applause when he talked about
we will get men out of women's sports
the crowd loved that they really they
really are jazzed on that that was an
important talking point for them he
brought in a couple of the candidates
that are running for for various uh
positions elected offices in the state
of wisconsin um and the ones he's
endorsing made compelling cases for them
and then he finished with some of the
the very enthusiastic st the way he
usually does talking about making
america great again and as always we
watch the crowd you gotta wait till you
end because you got to watch the
you know he didn't do it on stage he did
it on the steps on the way down he
didn't when he got to the bottom a lot
of these all those and then that and
there he is i will tell you i've seen
and i've been to some of these i've seen
almost all of them
there are varying degrees of
enthusiasm
this time a lot of enthusiasm he had a
lot of energy you know again he had the
weight the plane was delayed because the
weather he had the weight he finally
made it up to the stage and boy he
really he really run it excited crowd
all right let's bring back amy tarkanian
jesse jane duff and bruce lavelle for
some final thoughts we have a little bit
of time here um so let me bruce you know
you've been there you've seen it you've
been on the inside there what do you
what what was your assessment of the of
the president was he as i said very
enthusiastic maybe as enthusiastic we've
seen him since he left office
yeah well you know it reminds me one
time that 2015 uh we were landing in to
an event off this trump force one which
by the way he's getting a new one built
and he was
running off the plane and i watched
corey lendowski and i'm telling you
corey is a pretty fit guy he was
literally running chasing after this at
that time the 71 year old man with this
energy level which you which tonight
shows exactly what i saw back in 2015 at
74 years old but you know eric this is
this is exactly what the american people
need and real quick you know one of the
things that's very important is the is
the public safety and he knows being a
developer and and being successful in
hotels and all types of
real estate ventures there is no
prosperity and economic development
without public safety so he understands
the dire need he met he you know
resonated that message very well tonight
yeah and amy you know a lot of people
have said you know throughout this whole
year and a half uh it's time for him to
start looking forward uh instead of
backwards at 2020. it felt like
he did that tonight this was the first
one where he really focused on what he
had planned going forward he spent a
little bit of time on 22 but very very
little probably less than i've seen in
in all the rally campaign all the
rallies uh since you left office your
thoughts
right and i actually i thought he looked
refreshed and he actually looked younger
to me
so combined with his energy you know it
that's pretty incredible
um so yes i actually liked the way that
the speech was formatted i thought it
was wonderful that he did a quick um
reminder of where we once were and then
actually hit a depressing memory you
know down memory lane with the short
time joe biden has been president and
then finished off strong and positive
and uh you know america first and i
think it hit the nail on the head with
pretty much every topic
jesse about a minute or so maybe just
under a minute tell us we saw military
and law enforcement hat tip to them but
also another another very popular
talking point
yes people were pretty upset to watch 13
service members get killed in
afghanistan in that debacle of a
withdrawal it demonstrated right out of
the gate that joe biden had only been in
office since what seven months at that
point was an incompetent
commander-in-chief i love how president
trump tried in crt and all of these
other cultural issues how he had pulled
him out of the military and joe biden
put him right back in but there was one
key point made at the very beginning
that stuck out to me that the wisconsin
supreme court had ruled that the drop
boxes were actually illegal because they
had not gone through the state
legislature and he made a very valid
point that means they were illegal in
2020 and yet every time you pick up an
article that's written by a slightly
left or a left-wing media outlet they
continue to say trump repeats the lie
that the election was stolen trump has
these unfounded comments that the
election was stolen yet the evidence is
right there on so many levels that the
election was corrupted and president
trump continually points it out but they
don't want to repeat that and that's
what was critical in this last election
people turned out in arizona because
they were so fired up they came out with
the highest number in this midterm
election cycle that we have seen guys
ran out of time
i love having you on
jesse i love having you on jesse jane
duff amy tarkanian bruce levine say
thank you to all the guests who joined
us tonight prior to the to the speech in
waukesha wisconsin again a very very
important state for uh the presidential
run as well as the 2022 newsmax again
the only channel bringing you
live and full coverage we thank you for
being here make sure you catch me on
weeknights on the balance right here 8
pm eastern and again at midnight eastern
we wish every single one of you
a very blessed and safe weekend again
waukesha wisconsin great night
president trump
stole the show have a great night
everyone have a great weekend
[Music]
all right a culture so mortified of
offending lgbtq that it refuses to
protect
kids
let's check it out
[Music]
all right welcome to rob schmidt tonight
as a society we have devolved to the
point where we are so horrified of
potentially offending certain groups
that we suffer horrible consequences
in turn plenty of examples of that for
years liberals have refused to really
talk about inner city crime because
they're horrified to address a racial
racial issue it's just easier to let
thousands of young mostly black men die
every single year than address the
problem fixing the problem would require
an uncomfortable conversation
that white liberals are afraid would be
found to be offensive
we are so paralyzed with fear of
offending other cultures that we make
your 80 year old grandmother get a full
body pat down at the airport also we can
say that we have a random screening
process which of course makes us less
safe but shrouds us in the comfort of
political correctness and more recently
woke society has demanded that
protecting the very sensitive lgbtq
community trumps the safety of our
children and there are examples of this
all over the place monkey pox is the new
hot pandemic the media loves to over
exaggerate it is now a public health
emergency in every left-wing state
basically and also nationwide thanks to
joe biden's ridiculous and woke health
officials it's pretty bizarre as it's
only infected 7 000 americans and not
killed one single person but it's a
public health emergency
so monkey pox is nowhere near highly
transmissible we know that right the
numbers prove it right there in fact
it's quite difficult to catch if it's
only got 7000 in all these months
and the actual facts indicate that
sexual orgies are actually the prime
culprit of catching this disease
according to reuters in spain madrid
authorities are working on tracing the
cases mainly from a single outbreak in a
sauna the word sauna used in spain to
describe establishments popular with gay
men who are looking for sex according to
nbc news the leading theory to explain
the spread of the disease was sexual
transmission among gay and bisexual men
at two different raves that were held in
spain
and belgium
as we followed this story over the
months the cause of monkey pox became
exceedingly clear you can see it right
there
but then we started hearing about kids
getting monkey pox
and most normal people when they heard
that story became very concerned they
thought oh i thought this was spread by
close sexual contact mostly at sex
parties
how are children
getting monkey pox
and as soon as society got to that point
where that question arose the
conversation was ended forcefully
by being labeled as a bigoted
conversation
watch here is cdc director rachelle
wolinski utterly terrified
to answer a question about kids and
monkey pox listen to the wording that
she uses here she's so nervous about it
you would think she was walking through
a field of landmines
both of those children are traced back
to uh individuals who come from the men
who have sex with men community the gay
ma mend community
and so when we have seen those cases in
children they have generally been what i
call adjacent to the community most at
risk
adjacent
and the men on men having sex community
which is a new one by me uh a disease
that's almost exclusively spread by
group sex
shows up in little kids
and rachelle wolensky citing no actual
evidence whatsoever
is not concerned about it at all and
says it's just adjacent to the community
the cdc later would
force that up
by putting out this statement monkey pox
spreads through close skin to skin
contact which in the case of children
could include holding cuddling feeding
as well as through shared towels bedding
cups and utensils
maybe that's true
but again
it's this weird new pandemic that only
has 7 000 cases in several months
but for some reason in kids it's just so
easily spread by just you just touch a
kid pat them on the back and they get
monkey pox
how sure are we that monkey pox is that
easily transmissible to kids how can we
be sure what happened to the children
who have monkey pox well we certainly
can't investigate it we know that
that is not politically correct you
cannot investigate this we've learned
that
more examples of society's chaotic new
order almost overnight it's become
expected that you allow biological men
with breast implants dance naked in
front of your small children it is part
of pride
never question this
look at this video from san francisco
right here these are fully nude men
riding around on bikes
completely
riding around in circles in front of
little kids look on the right here when
it pans back over look at the little
girl
does she look like she's having fun
if you have a problem with this you're a
bigot we know that
another new standard women are not
allowed to be angry when a biological
man eviscerates them in a competition
and so the vast majority of young girls
in sports have to secretly complain
about our nation's latest embarrassment
while nodding and approving publicly
putting the rainbow flags on all their
instagram posts every june an
emotionally vacant nod to the culture
police
in locker rooms women are now expected
to be comfortable seeing a penis on
occasion in los angeles last year women
in a female spa
in a female area of a spa
were horrified